capital à malick avec la du mali
capitale du mali niamey ça c'est une
chanson sénat pouya mais niamey la mer
attention pour lequel le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait avec nous ce soir
thierry jean-pierre révélations sur les
frégates de taïwan
joe drake l'europhile ma nouvelle vie
bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h
nouveau cd
nouvelle vie
tapissez johnson cap et jeudi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le procès où elle vit
le chanteur de depeche mode
[Applaudissements]
et là
pas des litiges en roman formidable
lebron
un hommage à philippe corti
[Musique]
alors ma vie
oh
ans
[Applaudissements]
monsieur l'inégalable honda fit comment
savalan très bien et toi tu irais ça va
très bien parce que la semaine dernière
on a fait à peu près notre score
habituel face à la star academy
merci aux intermittents merci aux
internautes un bon pour que de venir
interrompre notre mission là non parce
qu'elle a enregistrés voilà on pourrait
les avantages vaut mieux l'interrompent
fogiel son directeur
bienvenue aussi parlé de millas et
allemagne les deux jeunes filles voilées
d'aubervilliers
j'ai reçu de nombreux mails les
concernant bah écoutez tout le monde en
parle c'est l'émission où tout le monde
peut parler voilà donc je donne la
parole à tout le monde même si je suis
pas toujours d'accord avec eux et j'ai
une devise que j'ai déjà expliqué ici
c'est je ne partage pas vos idées mais
je suis prêt à mourir pour que vous
puissiez les exprimer voilà ce que c'est
voltaire kalisa
à
les dirty musique commencera lui faisait
finir le boulot les mecs là bah ouais vu
que la première fois ça s'est bien passé
c'était super tout le monde nous a fait
les bons jours comment ça va 2 les vous
allez faire quoi
aujourd'hui ouais moi je suis pas si les
bandes la ouais bon allez au boulot
j'accueille maintenant thierry
jean-pierre
[Musique]
et
bonsoir bienvenue et abécassis bonsoir
thierry j'en ai assez des ventes de la
semaine dernière la cité trompette
dossier l'ordre thierry jean-pierre
ancien juge d'instruction est devenu
célèbre sous le nom de deux juges jean
pierre au moment de la sphère urba
gracco donc du scandale du financement
du parti socialiste auteur de nombreux
best seller avocat et député européen
au nom du parti démocratie libérale de
hama madelin voilà alors que livre est
publié chez robert laffont
ça s'appelle taiwan connection scandale
et meurtres au coeur de la république et
s'est consacré à la fameuse affaire des
frégates de taïwan dont on déjà parler
christine deviers joncour et roland
dumas alors faire en gros l'histoire
malgré les accords qui lient la france à
la république populaire de chine
la france a vendu du matériel est la
chine nationaliste c'est à dire ex
formule taiwan et les gens qui ont
permis ce marché c'est normal ont reçu
des commissions c'est le c'est le cas à
chaque fois qu'il ya des cas des marchés
sur ce très important sur les armes mais
là ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya eu
des rétrocommissions c'est à dire que
l'argent est revenu en france une partie
de l'argent à venue en france et on
pense que ça alimenter la caisse d'un
certain nombre de partis politiques
alors c'est une grosse affaire parce que
5 milliards de francs évaporée et
pratiquement une dizaine de mains c'est
beaucoup huit morts 8 - oui oui et puis
on est loin de la corruption politique
classique dans les années 90 au moment
de la sphère urbain le chiffre
d'affaires du rdda c'était quoi ces 100
millions de francs - là on est pour un
dossier à cinq milliards devraient donc
se démode ce montant de commissions est
absolument énorme est assez courant dans
le milieu de l'armement et ce qui est
assez courant aussi ce que découvert en
faisant cette enquête c'est les
règlements de compte
ouais c'est évidemment les affaires
d'espionnage mais c'est aussi les
assassinats commandités et c'est pour ça
que dans ce dossier notamment
il y à huit morts au moins un est mort
connus y en a beaucoup parlé de l'
affaire elf ou de la sphère du mas mais
par rapport à l' affaire des frégates de
taïwan c'est rien du tout on peut même
se demander on y viendra sans doute si
finalement la faire elle fait la sphère
dumas ne sont pas des diversions
organise
et pour étouffer l affaire des frégates
de taïwan non je ne pense pas parce que
d'inconnus financier l'affairé elf au
aurait dû être si elle avait été à son
terme une énorme affaire mais par contre
au niveau du disparition ouais au niveau
des assassinats il est évident que ça
n'a pas de ça n'a pas de rapport
alors vous parlez de votre mystérieux
informateur thierry jean-pierre que vous
avez l'homme au cigare je connais alors
peut-être plusieurs hommes peut-être une
femme enfin tous les cas évidemment vous
avez pas nous dire qui c'est qui vous a
balancé les les infos alors on reprend
les choses au départ au départ
mitterrand hésite
il ya un accord avec la chine populaire
il ya une demande de la chine
nationaliste il ya deux clans il yad'un
côté roland dumas qui lui veut pas
vendre les frégates à taïwan
et puis un lobby pro taïwan avec
chevènement edith cresson jacques attali
et finalement mitterrand s'est pas très
bien quoi faire et pour décider du match
les raisons qui a décidé du mas c'est
que alfred sirven décide d'utiliser
christine deviers joncour la [ __ ] de
la république qui est censé faire
changer roland dumas de la ville c'est
ça oui oui c'est ça mais sachant que le
réseau sirven devaient être payés mais à
des proportions finalement assez faible
oui puisque sur les cinq milliards oui
par rapport aux 5 milliard cent millions
de francs
serrières dangereux oui finalement alors
le groupe de pression s'organise là il
ya beaucoup de voyages d'hommes
politiques français à taiwan
jean-michel jeunes nés jean marie le
guen cambadélis strauss kahn marie
d'edith cresson est ce que vous croyez
qu'ils sont invités à taiwan et qu'ils
sont bien traités pour les amener à
faire pression sur le président
mitterrand il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
français surtout à gauche d'ailleurs
nous en l'espèce qui est qu'ils arrivent
à taiwan et qui essaient de profiter
effectivement de la man 2
taiwan taiwan à l'époque et d'un des
pays les plus riches du monde 100
milliards de dollars de réserves et en
plus taiwan paie cash
donc en veut toujours à taïwan on veut
vendre synchrotron des satellites un tgv
métro des grandes surfaces que sais-je
encore on veut tout vendre et dans le
domaine de l'armement tous les grands
industriels de l'armement se précipite à
taïwan de façon à essayer de tout vendre
et au passage des commissions sont
versés et des rétrocommissions aurait en
france vient alors finalement roland
dumas a fini par conseiller à françois
mitterrand de donner le feu vert à la
vente commence à ce qu'il change d'avis
comme ça brutalement après un voyage à
pékin
justement un voyage à pékin avec
quelques signes deviers joncour donc on
sait pas ce qui s'est passé plein dans
l'autre on revient sur ses positions
jouer séquelles de d il faudrait il
faudrait lui poser la question je crois
qu'après alors roland roland dumas
change d'avis en fait ce qui va mettre
le souk
c'est le refus de thomson qui vendait
les frégates à taïwan qui était le
fabricant le refus de thompson et son
patron alain gomes de payer les réseaux
sirven qui pourtant l'avait aidé et en
fait si on peut penser que si thomson
avait payé ce qu'ils devaient à sirven
les 160 millions de francs n'y aurait
jamais eu d'affaires elles furent jamais
de faire du mal et peut-être pas d'
affaire des frégates de taïwan gens ne
réalisent affaire des frégates ces
soirées c'est assez étonnant de les voir
se bagarrer comme ça donc il ya un
procès en suisse devant un tribunal
arbitral procès que gagne sirven
d'ailleurs aimé donc il ne peut pas
profiter parce qu'il part en cavale en
effervescence que vrai ouais donc il y
aurait pas eu ce refus de thomson de
payer nous contribuables français on
n'aurait jamais rien su quoi
probablement pas ouais donc c'est à dire
qu'il ya peut-être d'autres affaires
comme ça mais il y en a sur chaque gros
contrats d'armement est évidemment et en
écrivant ce bouquin ce qui est qui mois
maintenant beaucoup surpris c'est de
découvrir un monde que je ne connaissais
pas du tout et quand même assez
extraordinaire assez hallucinant où la
vie ne vaut pas grand chose
il parle en milliards de 1000 euros et
un contrat ça vaut un petit contrat ça
vaut 4 5000 euros thierry par exemple si
on veut supprimer
meiway cinquante mille balles et c'est
vrai mais pas chers et non c'est usher
et donc c'est quand même un univers
assez particulier alors dumas lui pour
se défendre effectivement il essaiera de
recentrer son histoire sur les sur les
milliards des frégates mais finalement
jamais la sphère ne remontera à la
surface d'une certaine façon jamais il
faudra que qui est une enquête en suisse
quand même un comble ouais la justice
viennent de suisse qui est une enquête
en suisse pour blanchiment et je veux en
faire l'un ouais donc enfin le l'enquète
sont ouvertes en france alors eva joly
et laurence vichnievsky refuse d'un
dossier alors qu'elle en aurait instruit
plein avec quelle quelle hargne a au nom
distel des intérêts supérieurs de l'état
ce qui est totalement incompréhensible
crois qu'elle était totalement nubie
leppard humains épars et par l'affairé
elf
mais elles n'ont pas voulu ça c'est
clair s'occuper de l' affaire des
frégates et le parquet de paris non plus
arranger tout le monde
alors il faudra attendre le juge renaud
van ruymbeke donc pour qu'il ouvre une
information mais ces dix ans après les
faits pratique
oui et puis toutes les enquêtes sur les
sur les assassinats commis un assassinat
193 comme enquêter sur un assassinat
nains taiwan pour le coup autant donner
après les faits alors quand on veut
savoir qui a touché ce pognon parce
qu'il ya quand même un paquet là pour le
coin on répond secret défense soit oui
on répond secret défense et sert c'est
aussi c'est une particularité franco
française c'est à dire on est le seul
pays quasiment 6 avec l'italie de
berlusconi
on est le seul pays dans le domaine
demande occidentale à confondre le
secret défense est le secret des flux
financiers c'est à dire on dit non
seulement le secret défense
c'est le secret de la fabrication des
vedettes des avions des bateaux etc
mais c'est aussi les flux financiers
douteux et c'est aussi l'argent des
corrompus c'est ceci aussi bien à droite
qu'à gauche on dira c'est laurent fabius
qui dit non je ne devrais pas le secret
défense
et puis aujourd'hui il ya quelques mois
c'est francis mer qui lit non je lèverai
pas le secret des formes notre galerie
non seulement ils lèvent pas le secret
défense mais en plus ils étendent aux
problèmes financiers ouais parce que
c'est pas seul à sepang et son armement
une question de pognon là
ça veut dire non mais c'est très
important dire que laurent fabius
d'abord -mr ensuite 10 on ne veut pas
qu'ee dans la quête sur cette affaire et
pour toutes les affaires de ventes
d'armes ça va être la même chose ça va
être la même chose aujourd'hui
les taiwanais sont en train d'enquêter
sur un autre dossier qui est celui des
mirages way et celui des missiles vendus
par matra à taïwan quand le dossier
arrivera en france en mai hier la même
chose mais il n'ira secret défense et
sur l' affaire des frégates
il y a aujourd'hui dans un coffre la
direction générale des douanes ya un
feuillet avec 19 noms est ce ce que ce
feuillet est évidemment frappé par le
secret défense
alors que ce sont le nom ce sont là les
noms des intermédiaires et des
bénéficiaires et ça c'est les
commissions et en cela c'est le joker de
la république
tout ça à l'époque pasqua de paulhan
maire des lilas secret défense pour le
rainbow warrior c'était pareil alors pas
sauf que là c'est une question de pognon
c'est pas une question de défense
bien sûr c'est une question de c'est
uniquement ça c'est pour protéger les
bénéficiaires de rétrocommissions qui
sommes dès qu'ils sont des hommes et des
femmes politiques français qui ont perçu
l'argent j'avais une idée vous de qui ça
peut être oui j'ai une idée mais je ne
suis pas le dire la haye pourquoi mais
juste un nom de famille n'ont rien du
tout même pas après n'engagent à rien tu
dire pourquoi c'est grave je vous dire
pourquoi c'est grave parce que là on
voit par exemple dans la sphère de
l'assurance american exécutif life c'est
les français c'est les contribuables
français qui vont devoir payer les
conneries des mecs qui ont racheté cette
compagnie d'assurance états unis et la
serre c'est nous qui allons payer au
lieu de faire des crèches des hôpitaux
et dernier lieu d'habitat oui mais là en
l'occurrence c'est pareil taïwan va
demander des comptes j'imagine mais il
est entre mes taiwan demandé deco ont
pas là l'année vermeille et qui va payer
c'est nous qui allons payer parce que
j'ai découvert aussi les contribuables
je veux pas faire de pub réalisme la
petite semaine
enfin je serais quand même insensé que
dans deux cas consécutif la sphère
d'exécutif lac et maintenant la sphère
des frégates de taïwan ce soient les
contribuables français qui sont obligés
de payer parce que des mecs se sont
beaux et les fouilles à la mémé c'est
pire que ça parce que là non seulement
non seulement la france va devoir payer
parce qu'il ya un contrat secret que je
révèle dans le bouquin va devoir payer
700 millions d'euros
à cause de ce sinistre là mais en plus
les sommes qui ont été saisies en suisse
sur les comptes d'un intermédiaire il a
été saisi 800 millions de dollars 800
millions de dollars
la justice suisse va être obligé de
restituer ces sommes à l'intermédiaire
parce que le dossier en france qui est
suivi par van ruymbeke va probablement
faire l'objet d'un non lieu et que donc
l' affaire de blanchiment s'arrêter
alors où sont passés les milliards alors
il ya quand même des rumeurs on vous dit
voilà ça aurait servi à financer les
campagnes présidentielles en 95 qu'on
m'a raconté mais vraiment de première
main l'homme au cigare
non c'est pas l'homme au cigare c'est
quelqu'un d'autre on m'a raconté que à
l'occasion des campagnes présidentielles
il y avait un des types des grandes
entreprises nationales qui était chargé
de faire la tournée des grands ducs une
fois par mois et qui avait régulièrement
donc une fois par mois quand ils
allaient dans les différents sièges ou
chez les différents hommes et femmes
politiques qui touchait il avait un
coffre de voiture dans le fond était
tapissé de liasses de billets de 500
francs
les billets de 500 francs à l'époque il
en balade et un mètre cube les mois ci
vous dire quel argent liquide circulé à
l'époque donc évidemment il ya des
suspicions de financement occulte non
évidemment
apparemment si ça fait pas plus de
vagues ça c'est que la droite et la
gauche ont touché les deux sinon l'un
balancerait l'autre évidemment que la
droite et la gauche ont touché voilà
évidemment qu'il ya une connivence qui
est absolument insupportable parce que
finalement là comme dans la sphère du
crédit lyonnais s'est évidemment notre
argent qui est en cause c'est nous qui
payons nos factures aubry c'est nous qui
en plus encore une fois c'est de
l'argent qui servira pas autre chose
alors il faudrait lever le secret
défense à la seule solution pour le
moment c'est la coopération avec des
magistrats étrangers qui ne sont pas
soumis au secret défense
le père odin par exemple en suisse
perdent 1 mais ce qui est incroyable
dans ce dossier c'est que les il ya une
coopération judiciaire entre taiwan et
vaille avec la suisse avec le luxembourg
avec le liechtenstein avec le grand
cayman un caïman quand même une des
places fortes du blanchiment
seuls et qu'ils coopèrent dans ce
dossier est le seul pays à pas coopérer
c'est la france qui refuse les
commissions rogatoires avec taiwan et
avec les autres pays est totalement
hallucinant alors la seule solution
c'est quoi c'est l'opinion publique
c'est pour ça que vous avez facebook ah
oui mais oui bien sûr c'est l'opinion
publique c'est ce qu'on a fait les gens
90 l'époque personne ne voulait parler
une financement occulte de partis
politiques ou de corruption politique et
les juges ont réussi à faire sauter le
verrou mais avec une seule arme qui
alarme de l'opinion donc il va falloir
le faire là dessus
d'abord parce qu'il faut résoudre ses
problèmes de disparition de sassine à
vous trouver les coupables
vous trouvez les bénéficiaires des
commissions et puis ensuite parce que
j'ai beaucoup voyagé pour ce bouquet
rhin et et la france à l'étranger
maintenant une réputation de république
bananière
à cause de son système de
rétrocommissions qui est mis en place
depuis une vingtaine d'années et c'est
absolument insupportable
sérieusement parce que vous me faites
penser un peu à d'aubert qui se bat
depuis des années contre la mafia contre
le blanchiment etc
il est très courageux et françois
d'aubert mais il n'est pas arrivé à
grand chose et ce que vous avez pas peur
finalement d'y passer votre vie et que
ce soit un petit peu le pot de terre
contre le pot de fer on est arrivé à
plein de choses
il y aura plein de choses et notamment à
voir par exemple une cour pénale
internationale qui aurait imaginé sans
les états unis 1 mais qui aurait imaginé
il ya quinze ans une cour pénale
internationale donc on irait mais ces
changements là se font à l'échelle d'une
génération est pas de l epa de 10 ans
vous pensez qu'un jour on saura la
vérité sur cette affaire d'être égard on
va y arriver mais c'est tellement
scandaleux qu'on vous êtes confiant oui
parce que je suis optimiste de nature
sinon je le ferai pas le louper un merci
merci c'est les gens qui accueille one
connection
c'est certain la faune
c
ah oui
et
et maintenant et qui peuplent heureux
oh
on
vingt six gélules godrèche
[Musique]
goaleador dans ces rues qui est une
habituée judith de tout le monde en
parle on vous aime parce que vous êtes à
la fois sexy et romantique cochonnet
romantique le guillant la [ __ ]
innocente lola a le macho à la [ __ ]
tout de suite je suis mais lui il est
formidable alors là il ya un nouveau vip
ah oui non pas marie et non mais non pas
le mari célibataire toujours toujours
célibataire open bar coeur à prendre
open bar car apprendre non non c'est un
nouveau film est une comédie
alors c'est vrai au départ j'étais un
petit peu l'égérie de doillon d'assayas
de filières tout ça avec ridicule vous
êtes devenu une vraie actrice le droit
de avant tout d'une fausse mais ridicule
ça a été la consécration j'ai le droit
de jouer dans la cour des grands et
maintenant vous vous amusez alors
êtes-vous fait tout ça avec beaucoup de
plaisir sur un petit côté la comtesse de
paris je sais pas si vous avez connu la
comtesse de paris elle avait elle a
écrit un livre qui s'appelait tous mes
bonheurs cucul la praline qua non non
non j'ai dit non non non non tonnage
alors si je dis de gobi jouer ça ça oui
c'est pas mal au derche si tu peux me
tais tu dors un peu non je m'en branle
j'accepte ailleurs fait dans le monde de
test
elle est décidée l atm ici c'est bien
catherine barma me dit que maintenant
bruno c'est laurent serait en train
d'abuser d'hélène ségara dans la dans le
carré vieille mais on comprend les
bonnes hélène qui dit que c'est pas elle
qui abuse de nous fais gaffe
j'essaie mais sinon copines ou dont
copie nous faisons ça va pas me faire
traiter de copines ou et l'ani à trop de
gens qui t'aiment
donc le film qui vous amène cher judith
godrèche c'est une comédie de tonie
marshall avec karin viard françois
cluzet micheline presle nathalie baye
hélène fillières bernard menez qui
s'appelle france boutique alors
l'histoire sucre sans taxation mais
voilà alors c'est l'histoire d'un couple
composé de karin viard et de françois
cluzet qui ont créé une entreprise de
télé achat qui s'appelle france
boutiques dont ils sont les
présentateurs vedettes mais france
boutique accuse un petit tassement des
ventes ça va un petit peu moins bien et
il trouve une partenaire une société de
vente sur internet qui est dirigée par
nathalie baye qui veut les faire chuter
pour récupérer le temps d'antenne voilà
voilà l'intrigué alors c'est un univers
très très cheap qui est assez bien assez
bien décrit les personnages sont assez
bien construit s'éclipser et vous
idéalisez et vous judith vous êtes
présentatrice jeu tamis de la patronne
karin viard espèce de bimbo peroxydée
mais pas con non naïve c'est à dire que
pour elle le téléachat c'est une fin en
soi c'est vraiment elle pense qu'on peut
aller toujours plus haut alors je
présentatrice vedette avec karine et
françois mayle pense qu'on peut aller
encore plus haut c'est à dire qu'au
dessus je sais pas vraiment ce qu'il y a
mais tu vas à l'avancé
1 c'est un tremplin quoi et elle est
ravie d'être là comme avant elle faisait
du porno bon mal c'est mieux ça mieux
c'est plus reposant
ça a changé quoi dans votre vie de
devenir blonde platine judith je pensais
que ça allait changer beaucoup de choses
on m'avait dit justement que les
voitures allaient s'arrêter que je
pourrai traverser au feu vert et ses
seins et c'est vrai que les premiers
jours on a le sentiment qui se passe
quelque chose en fait non je crois pas
ces différences dans la façon de
s'habiller si tu mets une jupe un peu
courte et que tu es blonde s'est lassé
la tff vraiment et houlette cité brune
ça passe mieux
je vais rester blonde comme ça mon
prochain film wiseid long et ça y est
c'est donc ouais mais je le reste reste
la même couleur pour nous un rôle à huy
est obligé de tourner à tuer celle qui
m'en parlent
elle m'a vu mon koala elle te parle de
ses poils pubiens gros prix cecil b
plusieurs mères faisaient pas de tweet
après huit ans sortir t'as pas envie de
jouer un rôle de route un jour te prend
six jours bonjour à tous alors france on
récapitule les points forts de notre
ensemble papa qu'est ce que tu peux
fermer
ce sont des boutons bijoux les crocs non
pour soi et mange quoi meurent en france
j'ai vu l'ensemble femmes forment ya pas
un peu de mou dans les bons oui oui je
pourrais peut-être le présenter un peu
différemment tu sais un peu plus comme
ça et bien ce blond c'est plus moderne
ouais merci moi je la comprends bien
sofia à l'essai de nous faire muter
femme nue et si tu préfères que tu n'es
pas très juste une pénétration vite ici
ma montre mais c'est aussi un petit
couteau pointu que je pourrais par
exemple planter dans le coeur de mon
amoureuse si celui ci n'est pas gentil
avec moi la période je te rends compte
que tu vas faire couler la gouache cette
boîte et autant à moi qu'à toi c'est
bien la seule chose qui nous reste en
commun c'est pas moderne fois et dernier
du vin un peu de métier un peu de soi
même un peu de métier suite leurs portes
du neuf
ce carré magique est un carré à
décongeler derrière l'a fait c'est un
endroit où je croyais ne pas avoir la
moindre lichette de cellulite et bien
pourtant mais si nous aimons être
élégante enfin deux femmes nous aimons
aussi l'enlever pour pouvoir nous
montrer sous un autre jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons passé quelques minutes pour
réfléchir et notre morceau de cabillaud
presque totalement décongelé
quoi france boutique de tonie marshall
avec karin viard françois cusey les
gimmicks godrèche et le train invité ce
soir avec plaisir alors quand on voit le
film et quand on voit votre performance
dans ce film sérieusement on a du mal à
croire qu'à la même époque vous étiez en
train de vous séparer de dany boon
non mais je crois que les êtres humains
ont une capacité ont une force vitale
qui fait qu'ils peuvent vivre des choses
assez difficile et en même temps sublime
et justement la réalité et à travers
notre métier on arrive à échapper à la
réalité
et justement le fait de faire une
comédie et d'être entouré par des gens
fin tony a été très proche de moi m'a
beaucoup aidé pendant pendant ces
moments là et une séparation c'est
toujours difficile mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit le générique de début et
de fin du film il ya des scènes d'un pro
et quand je vois ça je me dis mais
comment j'ai pu faire de l'impro vous à
vous avez une force mikala incroyable on
a tout ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
danny hart est un petit côté voici gala
annoncé noter tout est noté qu'ils
allaient me demande de relancer
sur dany boon qui va moi personnellement
je m'en tape un peu tout ça mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé comme dans toutes les
histoires d'amour on peut rester des
années ensemble et puis on peut ne pas
rester des années ensemble c'est bien
que non la réponse que je formule à
thierry il m'a dit c'est pas suffisant
venu là l'impact survenu il m'a parlé de
ça et tout donc j'avais les mains comme
ça dans le dos et je me rendais pas
compte puisque j'étais en train de
parler tu vas je me rendais pas compte
de ce qui se passait et pendant ce temps
il y avait un cameraman qui filme et mes
doigts et donc tout le monde m'a dit
était génial chez atos c'est j'espère
que c'est pas pour tout le monde pareil
[Rires]
bien non mais moi je faisais ça en
prenant une douche au sort bien alors
j'ai dit concentré vous un petit peu bon
voilà voilà
non je crois qu'avec dany en vain c'est
là ce qui les a pas on l'a reçue la
semaine dernière est ce que les abos oui
ah bon il fait faux j lr 10 ans s'était
donné la chanteuse ou par les parents
alors est elle le personnage de france
boutis dont dany la chanteuse
des moindres - les gens et on croit que
c'est monté non ce qui les a tués avec
ghani je peux te le dire maintenant
c'est la médiatisation quand on faisait
l'amour sous les caméras bas c'était
gênant pour pour tout le monde
je l'aimais yoko ono ça les a pas des
remparts ils sont plus ensemble
c'est chiant mais qui a tout le temps
avant d'être moche ça hein j'ai rien à
dire je suis dit tu pourrais vivre avec
un mec comme lui sinon elle a déjà donné
dans les comics bien alors est elle le
personnage de france boutique est très
arriviste puisqu'on l'a dit elle veut
passer du du porno au téléachat et elle
est beaucoup plus services que vous
parce que vous quand vous parlez de
votre carrière vous dit judith godrèche
j'ai fait dans ma carrière tout ce qu'il
ne fallait pas faire
j'ai sacrifié ma carrière à des mecs je
suis pas parti faire des films aux états
unis parce que mon mec avait dû du
boulot en france où après j'ai fait un
enfant enfin si vous n'êtes pas très
arriver c'est vrai non je suis pas du
tout arriver c'est à dire que j'ai
jamais sujet j'arrive pas à penser à
allah au travail en termes de carrière
je viens un peu au jour le jour et en
fonction de ce que je ressens aide et de
mes sentiments
donc si c'est vrai que kankan
j'étais très amoureuse et je n'avais pas
envie de quitter partir d'être loin de
la personne avec qui j'étais je ne me
sentais pas le courage d'assumer en fait
mes propres désirs ou en tout cas mon
travail qui est pourtant une passion
mais c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
sur lequel j'essaie de m'améliorer de ce
côté là pour arriver à me réalisés en
tant que femme en tant qu'actrice en
tant que maîtresse
est-ce que vous est ce que vous pensez
vous et sacrifier un petit peu votre
carrière sur l'autel de l'amour ma
personne au moment où on décide de le
faire c'est pas un sacrifice
si les six ans l'adulte voilà vous êtes
quand même victime de ce qu'on appelle
l'amour fusionnel c'est à dire cette
idée de tout ramener à une seule
personne c'est à dire quand tu ne vit
qu'à travers l'autre mais je pense qu'en
fait c'est un truc assez féminin et les
femmes ont tendance un peu à se mettre
au second plan quand elle est amoureuse
je ne sais pas bien là avantage des
rêves de te demander si j'ai pas les
muscles du dos très je suis pas très
développée au niveau du dos sans
s'enflammer
non mais vous avez un côté infirmière
doit coûter infirmières quoi hein c'est
ça tu regardes du bonheur missionnaire
de l'amour non mais c'est vrai mais
toujours en mission de là pour aider les
jambes c'est magnifique
et si un jour vous tombiez sur un mec
qu'a pas besoin qu'on l'aide
ça m'aidera beaucoup penseriez avoue ce
jour là ouais bien c'est fini là votre
deuil là parce que vous dites quand on
se sépare de quelqu'un une tasse de dice
qui est tout à fait bien sûr ça très
bien c'est fini votre deuil là je vais
décoller il veut savoir si tu as rome
c'est pas savoir j'ai pas dit ça
non tout simplement lui c'est fini
magnéto l'arrière de blonde de paix
sympa quand même un mois je lui dis tu
reviens quand tu vois ça me fait plaisir
j'espère se terminer là ces soirées télé
en pyjama avec les avec les chaussettes
et tout ça avec mes ce qu'il faut aimer
en moi c'est le côté transformation
c'est à dire un soir ça peut être le
grand jeu
c'est ce que je dis la guêpière oui
asseoir l'auberge espagnole
oui et le lendemain mamie judith way et
quelque chose elle est déjà un séquel
soir c'est les soirs voilà sinon elle va
au supermarché
non il ya des trucs de fric des planons
chez judith godrèche ya les soirées télé
avec le pyjama des grosses chaussettes
il ya le caddie au supermarché voilà
quoi et alors
ce qui est incroyable alors là vraiment
je m'en doutais pas une seconde mais
c'est en préparant cette interview comme
quoi on ne connaît pas encore très très
bien c'est cette angoisse que vous avez
de la mort judith c'est fou ça comment
ça se fait ah je sais pas mais je
refoule complètement et malgré toutes
vos psychanalyse et ce n'est pas arrivé
à vous sentir de psychanalyse tout
recommencer je vais pas arriver à vous
débarrasser de de sa non non non non non
non c'est un truc mais c'est même pas
que je n'accepte pas c'est que je ne
veux même pas y penser parce que vous
avez déclaré mon testament est prêt je
veux dire c'est vraiment oui mais c'est
surtout ce responsable
oui vis-à-vis du petit format et des
chiens
non mais sans déconner
ma mère elle n'aime pas trop les chiens
bon ben moi je les prendrais vosgien
c'est vrai oui elle est entièrement ses
chiens et ses trois chats assez simple
s'il lui arrivait à rien tu prends sa
chatte com
bien alors donc pour essayer de lutter
contre cette peur cette angoisse de la
mort judith godrèche
on va y arriver vous allez voir on va
faire une interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
judith godrèche as tu joue au docteur
avec tes copains à l'école
oui à l'époque
as-tu péché par penser aux par action
ouais j'ai volé des bonbons ah mais
c'est tout un joueur docteur as-tu
baissier la bouche à la mouche à la moux
hammouche à la mouche
non oui non l'asticot je crois à thierry
tu as des chances
judith godrèche as tu déjà convoité
l'homme d'autrui ouais et hualan jamais
c'est vrai l'homme d'autrui jamais tu
déjà commis le péché d'adultère
non si enfin quand j'avais 13 ans devant
lui c'était qu'un garçon s'appelle
tristan que tu connais que tu connais
jean carmet était avec les oeufs
je suis à 13 ans non il ne manquerait
pas tu couches et pas 13 ans 16 ans non
non et aimé non non il y avait un autre
gars sont un peu après mais j'ai juste
un smatch croit gilles godrèche et as tu
déjà commis l'acte de chair sans volonté
reproductrices oui tu déjà pensé un
juppé de manière sexuelle nombre n'ont
par contre quand j'étais petit je
faisais un rêve
jacques martin le poursuivait dans la
forêt avec une piqûre
julie taton profiter de ta notoriété
pour draguer des garçons nom de daniel
epp les garçons qui font ça tu fais
semblant d'être occupés pour ne pas
donner d'argent un sdf non non je sais
pas simuler en fait
oh c'est parce que banny banny à
l'époque
as tu essayé pour échapper aux paparazzi
de te cacher derrière les oreilles de
dany boon france boutis de demain leur
charge avec
m
[Applaudissements]
vous dire encore
j'ai un cadeau pour vous qu'est ce c'est
assez très très bon c'est un petit
cadeau qu'on vous a préparé suis dit
avec la production mais c'est moisi
attend c'est super bon et maintenant il
ya
là
avec papa
voici bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h
[Musique]
bonsoir
bonsoir comment ça va parfois je lis vos
soirées amis bonsoir les amis qui est
bataille qui font tél
bien alors caméra café en fer france
boutique on va faire le télé-achat alors
d'abord il ya caméra café la deuxième
saison l'intégrale en coffret 6 dvd dont
deux dvd de bonus
ben voilà regardez c'est peut-être s'est
inventé les scellés avec la secte pas
c'est pareil il marche bien la vraie vie
ce vol
ouais ça c'est la pole
c'est l'optimisation de tout ce qu'on a
fait pendant deux ans à savoir que
maintenant qu'ils avaient un café c'est
une entreprise bien huilé on a arrêté la
production ça continue il ya des inédits
jusqu'en juin 2004 la télévision mais on
était arrivé à une telle osmose entre
les comédiens la troupe en fait qu'on
avait réussi à créer et les auteurs que
effectivement maintenant il ya une
qualité assez régulière ce qui remet un
café ça se résume assez bien dans cette
intégrale et les bonus en poche c'est
pour faire plaisir c'est notamment tous
les caméra café les adaptations à
l'étranger et l'italie la grèce
voilà tous les pays qui ont acheté une
dizaine de pays quand je ne sais quoi
caméra cappuccino c'est ça mon chez moi
en chine ces caméras de surveillance et
en irak c'est bagdad qui a fait quoi là
bravo bon est ce que est ce qu'il le
vende bien là parce que tu sais que
judith vient de faire un film s'appelle
france boutique où elle est animatrice
de télé achat
qu'est ce que vous croyez sauf qu'il
s'est passé exprimé avec les mains il se
tient pas à ses droits ils sourient pas
assez et il parle pas des points forts
mais ça peut paraître prétentieux mais
on n'a même plus besoin de le vendre ça
se vend tout seul
c'est bien là sur les 100 sketch qu'on
tourne à peu près par saison là il y en
a une quarantaine qui sont la
quintessence même la substantifique
moelle de l'humour des caméras jeff pas
mal de france boutique donc sans la 29e
alors on continue caméra café puis à
pâques le capte les dvd en bd ouais ça
s'appelle tu en veux tu en veux voilà tu
en auras ses deux frères jumeaux vendait
tout est dit j'estime balle et un
troisième dessinateur il dit il écrivait
dessinent ensemble et c'est à l'issue de
la projection de caméra café en belgique
parce que c'est aussi exploité en
belgique qu'ils ont décidé nous ont
contactés nous aujourd'hui on aimerait
faire une bd autour des personnages
caméra café
voilà et c'est donc une initiative et ça
nous a plu ils nous ont montré et les
croquis on les trouve à plutôt bien il
ya c'est vrai ouais ils t'ont pas mis
assez de trains de revendeurs çà et là
ça va partir
lisons pas bien ses tresses état d un
non mais tu veux ton visage est trop il
allait cesser si le principe d'une
caricature c de la b d'action
will et buriné mon camarade romain n'a
pas un gros nez comme ça mais gros nez
n'a jamais d'effleurer joli visage à
bientôt il y aura les nuits caméra café
sur le modèle des nuit du zapping
en fait ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
de faire un label de caméra café parce
que c'est pas tous les jours qu'on fait
des choses qui fonctionnent à la
télévision et conduit succès paraît
effectivement tant qu'à nettoyer autant
faire briller donc on va en profiter
mais ça m'arrive en avant en profite et
donc effectivement il ya la bande
dessinée il ya le film qu'on est en
train de finir d'écrire avec nos
meilleurs auteurs et puis bientôt il y
aura un disque c'est à dire le disque on
voudrait profiter de notre petite
notoriété pour aider des collègues
annuler sa faim longtemps un bon moment
qu'on traîne dans la musique et on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya plein de mecs qui
sont très talentueux mais qui soit et
qui sont soit trop vieux pour passer à
star académie soit trop grosse ou arabe
soit pour rentrer dans les critères
donc on va essayer de leur donne leur
chance après un disque un discours donne
la chance à des groupes qui n'ont pas eu
la chance de signer justement et on va
faire découvrir au travers le label
caméra café
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu vois je dis
tu abandonné qu'il tient je dit je
conserve toi tu vois c'est un belle fin
de saison
c'est pas des rien de ces mois ci tente
de réagir par rapport à ton cadeau vous
êtes des salles où un problème elle
signe du reste est ouverte c'est vrai je
vous assurez la on va regarder non non
non c'est bon des cadeaux aux gens comme
vous donc je voulais vous gâter ses on
va le goûter tout ça ensemble et je fais
des fleurs maintenant quand tu le sens
faut que jeanne beker fonction un joli
moment de télé il faut qu'ils aient un
truc qui se passe entre vous peut-être
pas maintenant voilà attend d'accord tu
gères c'est toi qui gère ces tombes ok
tu dirais tu as acheté avec ton argent
le sétois je sais donc il va y avoir
tout plein de choses caméra café des
cravates des pas être trop cynique par
rapport à ça c'est pas vrai c'est pas
tout pour notre pomme quoi redistribuer
une partie de l'argent qu'ils gagnent
souvent à des années mais c'est vrai les
droits de noir était donné à droite
le neige parce que voilà et un
personnage on fera pareil aussi pour la
une partie de la bd pour le disque aussi
on va faire des fonds de soutien pour
des jeunes auteurs qu'est-ce que sa
branche maintenant je dit elle ne mange
alors comme ça alors regarde trop de
films pornos toi je t'ai pas vu dans
notre france boutiques en france boutis
j'essaie d'en revenir à mon film peut
traduire ces faits de manière presque
quatre fois on m'a dit c'est la dose ma
tête a raison mais fais ta promo ma
chérie ça j'essaie de faire ma promo
mais c'est pas évident non plus
forcément choisi la pâte interrompre ait
de conneries bien alors bruno vous aider
à assurer la direction d'acteurs d'une
d'une série de fictions courtes pour
france 2 qui commence lundi
qui va remplacer un gars une fille qui
s'appelle domicile adoré qui est produit
avec la même équipe qu'à caméra canon
cac alain kappauf et ouais ouais voilà
le pitch c'est un compositeur défunt qui
observent avec humour le quotidien de sa
famille recomposée depuis depuis l'au
delà
je suis les limbes voilà une belle idée
bah oui on pense que c'est une bonne
idée et la voilà on attendait une
vingtaine d'épisodes cédé 6 minutes
c'est effectivement sur le même format
un petit peu caméra café sauf que là
c'est plus académique où il ya des
champs contre champs c'est filmé comme
une série coin est vu par le prisme d'un
esprit qui observe donc c'est un
personnage famille personne le vois
personne ne va pas intervenu dans la
réalité il ne fait que commenter ce
qu'il est ce qu'il voit et là donc on
fait en a fait une trentaine de
l'épisode on en sait on est en train de
trouver le rythme qu'on avait dans
caméra café justement et essayer de
trouver cette même dynamique et
d'écriture et de jeu là pour l'instant
il ya des sketches qui sont
formidablement dans cet esprit là il y
en a qui sont un petit peu plus dans le
tâtonnement mais je pense que d'après
court terme on va créer cette même
troupe qu'on avait fait sans caméra café
chouette quoi bon dire que c'est bien de
réhabiliter d'expression chouette
et c'est un mot qui va revenir à avoir
peur allez j'en ai donc comme ça j'évite
les chouettes et ben il échoua tableau
même si c'est un peu dépassé mon côté un
peu puéril ça va échouer james
s'ébattent s'ébattent ses 100 saas voilà
c'était pas tant épatant si c'est
fragile estime ça c'était en france
beauté ah oui marre il peut payer soit
jamais celui ralentie et commandes tenus
par les produits et tu sais que j'en
fais supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
lundi j'étais absent maintenant que je
ne suis plus là j'ai décidé de ne plus
quitter maison près les noms qui me va
vers ça
missionné pour mais excuse moi même eu
l'indécence
non pas
et bah oui la maison a dit jean reno et
des singes oui c'est alice au pays des
merveilles comme cendrillon
moi je suis véhicules parcourant d'un
coup
[Musique]
une histoire de fou
domicile adoré la première fiction qui
est de l'esprit
voilà à domicile adressée lundi à 19h50
je pense deux énormes à tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours la chaîne
nous a donné combien de temps pour que
ça s'installe 50 mg héros 50 numéros le
moment parce que france 2 et m6 sont
qu'on produit france boutis ouais ouais
de benoist
j'ai mes enfants dans le nord c'est
chouette cette promesse et sans saveur
salée mais c'est la loi comme astrid la
tâche est presque dans la loge temps je
voudrais bien loin street à tribeca
est ce qu'on pourra voir un style
catherine
[Musique]
mon coeur
c
[Musique]
voilà mesdames messieurs je vous donne
en attendant je voudrais que nos amis
téléspectateurs comprennent comment ça
se passe du lied godrèche et là
évidemment il une attachée de presse
avec elle qui l'accompagnent qui
s'occupe d'elle sks bien maquillé ce
qu'elle est heureuse et c'est s'est
attaché de presse est là pour veiller à
ce que la promotion du film soit bien
fait
et quand on travaille pour
professionnels mines illégales on a
intérêt à assurer alors astrid bonsoir
alors astrid est ce que vous pensez que
la promotion de france boutique a été
bien fait
très concrètement oui pas ainsi donc est
ce qu'on pourrait dire de plus sur la
finalité traître est coupée pendant cet
internement ce qu'est ce que mais parce
que laurent lui avait alors si c'est ça
l'évolution devient ça mais je veux
qu'on appelle stéphane cette musique
[Musique]
sonné
comme beaucoup ici
ouais le monde alain kappauf
à
[Musique]
quand même tout à fait c'est lui notre
caméra café il y aura pas ils jouent mal
de temps je termine avec astrid ma
petite astrid très bonnes attaches est
passé de la tâche et pétales de la
vérité si je mens numéros 1 étoile a
souvent laissé je sais comme eric
laurent lui a pourri sa promo chu
d'accord d'accord commencé d'être
l'assistant de laurent baffie ces casses
couilles quand même non ça des gens
honnêtes soient négligés aulas répond je
te donne une carte de bons pilotes et on
va voir si ça marche parce que comme
c'est mon assistant je vais lui intimer
l'ordre de revenir il est bloqué au
passage on verra si c'est de la merde
s'écarte d'accord ça c'est bien
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus à des
niches tu te reposes il a droit de
partir est pas moins que tu es déjà
partie des anneaux logram au revoir
merci monsieur
l'abbr astrid
mais
m
[Musique]
et maintenant j'ai un cahier même ségara
bonsoir et n bon qu'est ce qui se passe
alors comme je sais qu'on peut couper au
montage
je vais ici je veux montrer mes seins
qu'est ce que je voudrais dire que vous
allez faire vachement de peine à ma mémé
avec ça parce que c'est fait maison et
que si un joueur n'est pas hermétique on
peut pas le savoir ce qui est fait
maison c'est toujours meilleur
un cadeau ça devient private joke ça
devient nutt la sphère du joint sa
vingtaine aux affaires des joints de
mener ça va être incroyable
m la grand mère d'hélène ségara à des
joints que son père métis et donc c'est
certain que c'est dur à vivre au
quotidien qu'il n'a pas dit à l'antenne
que c'était un cadeau de toile elle va
le reconnaître
et vous quel est son prénom elle va bien
sûr l épandage de reconnaître son projet
bien naturel qu'elle est centrée non
j'ai demandé à patates à droite parce
que j'ai une très bonne droite et le
prénom de sa grand mère
je ne regarde pas alors ça ne te regarde
pas quel que soit ton prénom c'est pas
très grave
ses rillettes sont moisis mais j'en
connais doigts c'est un cadeau que j'ai
fait à judith en lui faisant croire que
c'était moi qui allais coeur ça peut
arriver mais oui voilà ses petites
affaires est resté dix ans ici mais je
voulais vous le dire on est le prénom de
toi même et tu me fais chier je t'adore
m'avait-on handicap patronymique je suis
à 200 concerts avec toi beaucoup de
messages pour savoir quel est le prénom
de la mairie
dans le message c'est un café ta
grandeur sans déconner moi j'ai eu ma
petite mémé dans le sud-ouest qui fait
des foies gras délicieux sauf quand le
joint n'est pas l'émission parce que les
pauvres ils attendent toute la soirée on
peut le manger ce truc on peut bien sûr
c'est non c'est non mais si tu veux
c'est parti oui le podium
je sais pas où est le faux mails ou les
vidéos peau parce qu'il ne s'agisse pas
de bol c'est le mec qui t'offre un grand
pinard et manque de pot il a bouchonné
on sait comme les fleurs lâchant l'école
suppose dh effet sur un bord deux tons
geforce et le gazole
voilà je suis très gêné parce que je
savais pas que comme d'habitude c'est
quelque chose qui fait d'ailleurs ce qui
fait la vie impossible à combler l'écart
des plages qu'on sait tous les cas
d'obésité mais n'a jamais eu des
champignons bien sûr c'est la vie ça
arrive catherine c'est ce qu'elle m'a
dit 4 1 elle m'a dit je veux plus voir
se posent encore par les gendarmes a
fait qu elle n y paraît il ya quatre ans
[Musique]
j'avais bien pour les gens qu'ils
connaissent leur histoire bien oui il
s'égare en soit 34 ans dans le malienne
j'y allais l'a dit vous êtes resté dix
ans et garant le mariage vous réussit ce
mariage c'est passé le 30 août 2003 vous
avez épousé mathieu mathieu lecat 14 en
rappelant le nord faire de votre second
fils mathéo vous êtes voilà je savais
qu'on avait parlé de mon mari j'attends
mon bébé orlando et mon bouquin ou mon
passé à temps on aura fait tout bah oui
mais je savais que les dires c'est j'ai
moi-même a pas que j'ai perdu c'est
quand même dommage dommage et bien non
mais c'est normal qu'on parle de ça est
ce que c'est quand même bien moi je suis
désolé mais c'est une très belle
histoire
vous vous êtes rencontrés en 2001 chez
maxim's lors de la remise de votre
premier disque de diamant hélène ségara
et puis ensuite il ya eu deux ans de
grand amour et vous avez dit très
souvent que la différence d'âge n'était
pas un problème pour vingt cinq ans
d'écart c'est pas monstrueux gérer je me
sens pas être sa grand-mère où je ne
m'interdis pas tu sais j'ai deux enfants
j'ai ce qu'il faut pour faire ça
maintenant
ce qui est certain c'est que tout le
monde a parlé de ce mariage moi je
compte pas vivre ma vie cachée j'aime
quelqu'un
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est
qu'évidemment vu que certains paparazzi
avait loué l'appartement qui est en face
de la cathédrale on a vu du beau faire
non mais sérieusement c'est chouette on
n'a pas fait de faire part on appris de
la sécu y avait six mecs et ils ont
cassé les pieds bon ils ont été limités
agressif avec le photographe de famille
nous enfin tu vois mon donné quand toi
tu choisis de pavant de photos de ton
mariage quand tu choisi de garder un
événement intime pour toi parce que moi
j'avais envie de me marier à l'église
soit mais après ça fait la une de tous
les magazines les photos ont été vendus
revendu revendu revendus non moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup inquiété s'est créé saman
j'ai vu un article dans le gala sur le
fait que les femmes prenaient des maris
ou des amendes plus sévères les mecs
plus jeunes mais mais mais mais mais on
a choisi un mec de cinq ans vainqueur
mon dieu ça m'inquiète moi
personnellement
or à ma femme quand c'était la star
c'est à dire les mecs qui préfèrent les
petites jeunettes on en parle beaucoup
moins j'ai senti ce truc là soit en plus
des flux j'avais du pollen sur le blair
ça ces habitats personnes me l'a dit on
voit pas il ya par les crampes je vois
que je contrôle bruno tu as plein de
trucs mais ces fleurs l'annoncé au nom
de la nature en femme j'ai ouvert est ce
qu'on peut avancer un petit peu la
prochaine les gens ne pas que ça allait
alors donc mariage ajaccio à 11 heures
la mairie à 15 heures en la cathédrale
orlando témoins non mais tu vois tu les
trouves une mauvaise presse parce qu'ils
ont dit n'importe quoi julie zenatti
orlando témoins orlando m'a accompagné à
l'hôtel mais tellement restés mes amis
d'enfance et alors à l'hôtel ça donne
quoi c'est bien
comme quoi la différence l'agencé des
conneries ça va mal on passe en même
temps est-ce qu'on va y arriver donc
orlando pas témoin à son mariage
ah bon il est à patrick fiori ben oui
c'est ton ex fiori ben non pas moi à oui
plutôt oui c'est vrai accès à réchy
comparé gasquet moi hélène tiens je
suivais relancer le débat jeune fille
quand j'étais avec dernière salle et ça
a duré pas très très longtemps mais j'ai
quand même reçu des lettres de menaces
parce que j'étais une femme qui
détournait un jeune homme de son droit
chemin
je voudrais dire quand même que le père
de mon premier enfant à 20 ans de plus
que moi et que je me spécialise pas dans
la chair fraîche l'amour c'est l'amour
et on regarde pas en demande pas une
carte d'identité et basta quoi garder
arthur aussi au mariage
oui c'est un ami at war tuer c'est un
ami à moi c'est bizarre quand même des
amis tous arthur orlando tout ça ça
c'est pas amis excuse moi mais moi j'ai
pas fou qu il est pas venue en mai puis
on sai on attend excuse moi je après tu
pleures parce que c'est médiatisé il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui va parler on
parle d'abord d'aider ma de mes
meilleurs amis qui viennent du sud on
n'en parle pas parce que personne ne
connaît son affaire avec des gens
médiatisé alors oui avec garou parce que
je les aime profondément
we have et arthur parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui même s'il ne fait pas que
des choses que je cautionne et je suis
d'accord avec toi sur certaines choses
il a un grand coeur et je le défendrai
adore ça excuse moi il ya trop de gens
qui t'aiment lms qui est ce qui là est
ce qu'il a donné de l'argent la quête
arthur on alors
ces mariages et un enterrement le jour
d'un mariage tu crois que tu veux
regarder qui fait la quête et tu n'en
avais pas voilà tu t'es envier ses
tabliers comment j'étais habillé en
blanc avec une grande belle robe une
robe un peu plus simple pour l'amérique
très l'info de rillettes
c'était émouvant comment tu arrêtes et
et rillettes premier puisque hissé du
fond en menant d'abord raconté il défend
sa tête un foie gras au début ménage
peut t'arriver
non mais je peux dire c'est qu'il a un
jeu un père meetic ça m'est arrivé mais
on va peut-être pas faire l'émission
tout le monde en annonçant sa non non on
voudrait parler des fiançailles le
téléfilm en fait j'adore ce matin si tu
sais pourquoi je suis comme ça c'est
parce que tu m'as pas invité mais j'ai
pas un n'est pas assez intime je suis
désolé tiens ça tu l'as bien pris dans
la gueule il sera invité au prochain
tour
bizot termine en divorce donc je t'aime
beaucoup mais on sait on s'apprécie
quand on se croise je pense qu'on est
toujours au top précis quand on te
croiser mais n'est qu'il reste un peu
là-bas ça retombe
non mais tu sais ils vont elle a soulevé
un truc très intéressant et 2 et il a
parlé des pipoles de mon mariage je dis
alors parce que j'ai des amis dans ce
métier je vais pas les invités parce
qu'ils sont people maintenant non c'est
pas ça c'est qu'après si on s'étonne on
sait oui un petit peu quand même
non messieurs on s'étonne après qu'il
est dédé si tu évites madame michu ta
grand mère tanya saint-val et des chats
paradis alors qu'à partir du moment où
tu dis qu'ils ardisson qui va venir mais
pour me faire perdre et ne pas avoir
invité j'ai été amené un petit cadeau le
moisi tu vas adorer
est-ce que vos cadeaux entre et s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
doc gynéco je trouve que cette émission
est le manque de mascotte maintenant
tandja cadeau pour toi revient cette
année pour le bain s'amuser mais en fait
non c'est bon mais pourquoi bah oui oui
mais je me suis rabattu doit maintenant
chercher la patte droite
franchement on s'emmêle un peu les
émissions de tv n'atteindrait que 22,8
de lui-même
bien des égards on vous souhaite autant
de succès en amour que dans le métier
vous êtes là la success story de la
variété française de ces dernières
années est régulièrement c'est vrai
régulièrement désignée comme la
chanteuse préférée des français vous le
savez ça quand même
c'est très très gentil mais je pense que
ça s'est tue c'est l'amour ça va ça
vient quoi mais oui oui encore une
chanson est la rue mais notre dernier
album s'est déjà vendu à 500 mille
exemplaires au nom d'une femme le
précédent à 2 millions d'exemplaires
vous êtes la meilleure vendeuse
française je sais pas à moi je vous dis
bah écoutez je sais pas vous attendre à
fabio deux boîtes
tu rigoles m'attend mais là fabien elle
est là non non ça gêne pas parce que moi
ça veut dire c'est un marathon là moi
j'suis pas de marathon avec personne et
en plus de ça je fais pas de marathon
avec moi même c'est à dire tu as vendu
d'un million il faut que tu fais tu es
passé de mire non non non non non ça
n'occupe ci fonctionne tel chiffre c'est
une artiste voulu la paix elle sait pas
si elles vont elles
elle est créée non ça se passe quand je
suis content tu sais écoute moi oui je
sais pas si tu as vécu dans quinze
mètres carrés dans ta vie moi oui avec
mon fils et j'ai vraiment galéré
suffisamment pour être contente et
apprécier ce qui m'arrive vraiment
aujourd'hui
mais vous avez raison hellène moi je
suis sûr qu'elle a raison oui mais elle
est censée tu viens de 15 mètres carrés
et était été carrée humaine donc votre
dernier album est sorti au printemps
dernier hélène ségara album écrit en
collaboration avec maxime le forestier
lionel florence patrick juvet un album
avec beaucoup de chansons d'amour mais
aussi beaucoup de chansons engagées
beaucoup nous manquer d'une chanson par
exemple sur la pédophilie
vous êtes contre oui c'est sûr ça
totalement con une chanson sur les
enfants soldats
vous êtes content soit qu'on peut le
dire mais qui n'est pas content sur deux
comme le disent à part les personnes
malades et dérangé qui ont des enfants
comme ça mais qui n'est pas contre voilà
est un nouveau signal qui s'appelle on
n'oublie jamais rien
[Musique]
orlando exige l'équipe 1 messieurs
et
[Musique]
quoi
je n'ai rien hélène ségara est là
aussi voilà alors c'est des images qu
orlando m'a donné en exclusivité un
métier plus très bien à la maison dans
quinze jours
oui c'est une fois je lui ai dit qu'il
avait une apparence qui étaient fausses
et il m'a dit mais moi ce qui me gratte
pas le vernis ne m'intéresse pas je
mange avec orlando intime tu va un peu
loin
ah bah il vient dîner à la maison quand
même des fois t'es pas mis à mon mariage
alors je suis justement c'est très vite
et ça joue aussi bien alors cette loi
aura pas aussi ni avec qui ni chanter
cette chanson c'est celle qu'a fait la
solitudine vous connaissez cette chanson
alors maintenant on va faire un truc
personnes voilà donc la chanter je
l'adorais asie mais je connais pas la
tête non mais c'est pas grave juste un
peuple à la solitudine fran nom des
postes
voilà c'est ça c'est ça non ni possibile
et dvd la vie dans ces lots et non non
non non madame les menaces et la
solitude il alla pas aussi méchante
jamais
alors maintenant
maintenant il ya une tournée en france
et l'olympia du 3 au 8 novembre est ce
que vous êtes prête noms ça fait plaisir
à entendre
non mais brett prête oui mais on n'est
jamais prêt quel est le prénom de ta
grand mère je voudrais lui faire un
bisou
non je veux pas des bisous à toi
maintenant puissante et aux noix de
grand mère je suis sûr qu'un manoir ta
grand mère je parle en son nom je suis
sûr qu'elle va l'aimer mais mouly c'est
titi mais mollet c'est la batellerie
iata le pâté et bien bien
alors début novembre par et le livre de
didier le cas journaliste père de votre
mari mathieu lecat le livre s'appelle en
aparté et vous raconter hélène ségara
dans ce livre votre vie ouais bah si
quand même si une partie vous racontez
votre naissance par accident ça tu te
fais en mon nom j'ai fait un niveau très
vieux le truc il était il est comme ça
t'as pas vu je suis parti en arrière
mais aussi ses moments de panique ou tu
te sens pas me dire là c'est comme ça il
parle comme un vieux ces bons ne pas
dire je suis sûr c'est ce qui s'est dit
moins que permettez aucun je me disais
qu'il est en équilibre précaire choix
dans lequel m segarra dans ce livre qui
s'appelle un aparté vous raconter votre
vie votre naissance par accident alors
que vos parents ne rien comprendre que
c'est n'importe quoi vous ne savez pas
non mais là je les écoute par contre
j'ai fait un bts même sens donc c'est le
moment où elle l'est et je dis
simplement attenti ta suspendu elle
n'est pas attendue c'est ça que tu sous
tend ces parents ne s'entendent déjà
plus en mer mais merde
parler du bonheur vous avez non si c'est
moi je vous dis tout de suite si c'est
pour faire des plans comme ça sur la vie
d'hélène ségara moi j'en parle pas du
bouquin maintenant mèche hélène je
connais bulli depuis dix ans il n'a
jamais fait ça on peut lui accorder
c'est la dernière
bon alors donc dans ce livre vous
raconte hélène ségara votre naissance
par accident alors que vos parents ne
s'entendent déjà plus leur divorce huit
ans plus tard votre beau-père
pieds-noirs macho c'est pas le moment
plus jeune que votre mère oui ça aurait
dû vous mettre la puce à l'oreille ça
ben non moi justement le je pense que
c'est pas une question d'âge d'aimer les
enfants des autres ou pas d'accord c'est
lui ce cet homme qui vous a un petit peu
voler votre enfance enfants tous les cas
ce qu'il en restait et il est sans doute
à l'origine de la méfiance que vous avez
envers les hommes hélène ségara là
disons qu'il m'a appris à me battre très
jeune et ça peut être qu'il faut que je
l'en remercie même s'il est plus là mais
en tout cas où il m'a rendu très
méfiante et
il m'a fait grandir très vite mais je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vivent une histoire comme ça maintenant
la meilleure manière de dépasser tout ça
c'est de s'en sortir et de fond c'est
quand même
voilà vous raconter dans steve hélène
ségara votre départ de la maison et vos
retrouvailles avec votre mère beaucoup
plus tard quand vous êtes enceinte elle
revient vers vous vous racontez vos
débuts dans la chanson les piano-bars
nous endroit un peu louche un petit peu
mal famés dans les cups dix ans on n'est
qu'à vous êtes obligé de chanter dans la
région de hyères plein de plus passé
d'où le nom non non non mais ça je veux
dire je renie pas du tout c'est une très
bonne école et à paris j'ai même
travaillé dans un dans un bar où il y
avait des prostituées je les respecte
beaucoup parce qu'elles m'ont énormément
peu léger mais je te dirai voilà il ya
un scoop dans le bouquin c'est en fait
que pendant les années 80 hélène ségara
devient look destroy
vous étiez fans de depeche mode mais
vous savez que david kahn le leader de
depeche mode et là ce soir il va arriver
quand on lui a dit que vous étiez là il
dit je viens mais ça l'a bouleversé
longtemps que j'ai pris le téléphone il
va venir david gamme
j'étais fan de kurdes d'indochine et
l'ordre de metallica gjp comme moi tu
sais les gens il soit une idée et je
n'étais pas eu envie de faire cette
musique des serments paix parce que ça
qu'il faudrait pas à tester si tu vois
j'adore alanis morissette c'était la
plus proche de ce que matt asti tueur
vocale mais bon sincèrement j'étais
tellement révoltée pendant cette période
là que j'allais vers tout ce qui pouvait
m'aider à faire sortir cette révolte
et puis dans l'école où j'étais j'avais
un prof de maths qui m'autorisait à
chanter en cours et ça je crois pas que
ça dans le bouquin et mes camarades me
voyais vraiment comme quelqu'un de super
révolte et pas forcément de très dur
quoi qu'enchanter la douceur s'installer
et là je me faisais plein d'amis ça m'a
permis d'être aimée des autres et pour
moi ça a été
et elle habite finement le garde-à-vous
là plus personne par monsieur parce que
c'était émouvant témoignage qui avait
atteint les gens insensible brèche à
arrêter de parler de france méconnu dwan
daniel a tout arrêté
donc à chaque fois qu'il ya pu rien à
dire je crois que je crois que si on
voulait faire un petit break chez vous
allez prendre une bière à l'effet d'un
petit livre l'amour c'est l'amour oui
j'ai envie de me couper la télé faire
l'amour est alors alors ils ont tout ce
qu'on peut arrêter comme ça à l'époque
vous étiez pas du tout féminines 1 non
j'étais très garde son c'est marrant je
vois ce désir pas de flirt
non non très platonique fallait pas
comme tripote j'ai joué au football
et oui oui mais s'il fallait pas compte
triple r oui fallait pas me chercher
c'est vrai que j'étais trop mal avec la
moitié des garçons de mon école dans les
douches étaient chacuns passionnel plus
bien non mais c'était la magie de ces
gens adorent tirer quand tu fais tu
piges à sa récente était pas mal aussi
séquence 1 à à à
un seul nom attendez un seul homme
jusqu'à l'âge de 23 ans
hélas après vingt-trois hommes en un an
non non non alors d'autres questions là
dessus ben oui orlando d'ornans doubs ça
va bien c'est vrai bien non landau
orlando ça a été la rencontre de ma vie
c'est vrai est ce qu'ils exigent orlando
de ma vie mais je crois qu'il est
exigeant mais il est surtout
professionnelle c'est à dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui il a un tel recul sur ce
métier je crois que c'est un des
derniers comme ça dans ce métier il a
une oreille
il a une oreille et lui il arrive en
j'arrive en studio il sait si j'ai
pleuré ici c'est j'ai dormi c'est
comment je suis dedans j'ai rien à lui
dire quoi c'est dommage qu'ils soient
pas là je leur viande rasséréné rieth la
veille tombait bien j'avais difficile à
monter parce qu'on le dit tout les
dominer tridente orlando et ils exigent
on avait une interview si orlando
l'exigent
[Musique]
alors pour rester la chanteuse française
numéro un
hélène ségara si orlando l'exigeait ce
que vous seriez prête à manger un pot de
rillettes avariée nom est ce que vous
seriez prête à reprendre 6 kg non mais
là il faut que je perde a donc orlando
et orlando pour lui savait pas ce que
c'était d'avoir une artiste qui a une
grosse presse un don quand je l'annoncé
et c'est à dire à mon dieu aime active a
trop grosse
j'ai dit non je vais être enceinte et
donc j'ai fait ma grossesse comme toute
femme
et puis quand j'ai accouché me dit
maintenant tu as encore très grosse donc
forcément j'ai dit alors bat contre il
m'a sorti un truc très très joli c qui
m'a dit mais finalement qu'elle est
publique et même grosse a même ans un
petit m
et finalement si tu pouvais rester en
scène jusqu'au mois d'octobre à mai
j'accouche en est donc à l'ancienne a
lancé un jour
non mais là je suis au régime simplement
parce que ça m'agace les gens pas
compris que je n'ai de m aujourd'hui
tout est autre
alors est-ce que c'est orlando l'exigent
hélène ségara vous ferez gonfler encore
plus le nom mail exigeant il existe
d'abord il exigera jamais ça c'est pas
du tout branché bimbo sur l'endos
l'exigé ce que vous seriez prête à
chanter des chansons que vous ne
comprenez pas non non non tu me
demandera jamais ça mais tout si j'ai du
caractère il le sait voilà comme moi
j'essaie de temps en temps de lui dire
on peut pas en faire une petite un peu
plus rock'n'roll sur l'endos l'exigé ce
que vous seriez prête à voter françois
hollande aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
oui absolument questionnaire c'est le
fun dit pas ça non pas françois hollande
mais de façon non j'ai jamais c'est
marrant parce que la question je la pose
pratiquement toutes les semaines
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qui était prêt
à voter françois rime cette ségolène à
ségolène royal il est bon mais quand ils
en ont sérieusement comment ça se fait
que les gens ne veulent pas voter
françois hollande
ils sont prêts à voter fabius a mais
fabi c'est encore pire à moi ainsi on a
oublié l affaire du sang contaminé
gendarmes qui sont prêts à voter fabius
plutôt que françois hollande
tu sais je vais te dire un truc moi je
vais faire je vais laisser les
politiciens fait la politique
sincèrement il ya il ya des gens de
gauche que j'aime beaucoup
voilà par exemple j'aime beaucoup
delanoë copains orlando il est proche
des gens et je trouve que
mais pas que pour ça non si je suis
assez grande
il ya des gens encore lent douanes bien
que j'aime pas michou michou par exemple
là c'est mon paradis pas mal de neige
autant qu'aujourd'hui j'ai longtemps
moi j'adore me je te jure regardes et tu
crois que c'est même il n'ya que le bleu
qui change tout tu changes le bleu c'est
les mêmes d'un mois
[Musique]
je
apple en vacances et c'est
et maintenant alors voilà ça c'est un
truc pour vous maintenant là pour vous
de là vous étiez là le jour où thierry
meyssan est venu nous expliquer qu aucun
avion n'était tombé sur le pentax est
bien toi notre scepticisme et des
interrogations et des questions qu'on
lui a posé et à dieu dieu sait à quel
point nous avions raison d'un manque de
préparation oratoire et gagne pas ce
soir on va vous proposer un nouveau cas
ivan et bruno c'est qui a vraiment tué
john fitzgerald kennedy
voici william reymond et billy soliste
non
à quai
[Musique]
tous
bonsoir william reymond bonsoir billy
solstice donc que william reymond vous
êtes journaliste auteur notamment de
deux mini çi non coupable les assassins
retrouver le livre qui a servi de base
au téléfilm de tf1 et dans lequel vous
émettez l'hypothèse qu'en fait la
famille d'anglais la famille drummond
n'a pas été assassiné par gaston
dominici ou par l'un de ses enfants mais
par les services secrets voilà ça c'est
une thèse qui est très critiqué mais qui
a quand même séduit tf1 puisqu'ils ont
fait le thème de leurs deux téléfilms
exact cris critiquer mais très souvent
pour des raisons complètement fausses et
qui prouve encore une fois que les
journalistes télé
lorsqu'ils font des articles ne lis pas
les enquêtes et on m'a reproché des
choses qui est dans téléfilm en pensant
que je les avais écris moi alors que ce
n'est pas du tout le cas
voilà donc en tous les cas vous avez été
à l'honneur deux soirs de suite sur tf1
est aujourd'hui votre thèse sera sans
doute aussi critiqué mais nous avons là
deux experts qui seront plus longs et
yvan le bolloc'h qui ont déjoué thierry
meyssan je crois la première seconde et
on a tout de suite cru que c'était de la
flûte voilà rapport à messanges avait vu
l'émission d'ailleurs par rapport à mes
sens je me suis retrouvé souvent face à
l'huile dans des émissions de débat pour
dire un avion c'est bien créer la
surprise taiwan j'habite aux états unis
j'avais vécu ça quasiment en direct est
bon c'est thierry meyssan moi je ne suis
pas tiré mais sans non j passage dit
simplement vous avez la chance d'avoir
deux observateurs qui sont habitués aux
populations voilà alors le bouquin
s'appelle jfk le dernier témoin c'est
publié chez flammarion
alors sur la bande rouge sur le livia
marqué assassinat de kennedy enfin la
vérité 1 donc là sont fort sifflement
voilà alors le dernier témoin va cesser
c'est vous monsieur billy solstice donc
milliardaire texan ruiné et longtemps
financier du président lyndon johnson
que vous accuser d'avoir fait tuer john
kennedy pour qu'ils arrêtent de fouiner
dans les magouilles de johnson c'est ça
correct c'est ça alors là faire et est
sorti dans paris match elle sera
développée lundi soir dans lundi
investigation sur canal + sous le titre
edf qui autopsie d'un complot voilà
alors on va reprendre les choses 2 0
pour que tout le monde comprenne bien et
tout le monde puisse suivre alors le 22
novembre 63 john fitzgerald kennedy est
assassiné à dallas quelques heures plus
tard
lee harvey oswald est arrêté mais il est
immédiatement abattus par jack ruby
avant d'avoir eu le temps de s'expliquer
voilà que rêver qu'on surnommait
l'assassin de l'assassin voilà alors la
révélation du livre que vous publiez
tous les deux c'est qu'en fait il y
avait un deuxième tireur
oswald n'étais pas seul dans le dépôt de
livres au cinquième étage en face de
l'endroit où kennedy a été assassiné
auprès de lui dites vous il y aurait eu
un autre tireur un dénommé malcolm est
vrai toit l'as tu as au service du lobby
pétrolier texan tueur dont on n'a
retrouvé l'empreinte digitale sur place
donc déjà prenons ce point vous dites
qu'il y avait deux tireurs face à cannes
et lui avait il y avait deux tireurs
l'un d'entre eux était mal comme marc
mollet et l'autre hétéro secondes
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire que
wallace est elle à ce jour là au
cinquième étage du dépôt de livres
c'est le point de départ en fait de
l'enquète c'est la découverte
en 98 d'une empreinte qui avait déclassé
par les enquêteurs de l'époque rester
anonyme
et lorsqu'on la compare à un suspect qui
va être mal comme wallace on se rend
compte qu'en des plus grands experts
américains trouvent 33 points 3,33
points de comparaison aux états unis il
faut savoir si point de comparaison
suffisent pour envoyer quelqu'un à la
chaise électrique aérienne à 33 et 1 à
donc cette empreinte elle est
formellement identifié ans et pour des
raisons techniques je peux expliquer ici
qu'elle a été déposée au moment du crime
donc c'est la preuve qu'il y avait à
côté de lee harvey oswald un deuxième
tireur à dallas le vin d'honneur ça sent
trop la voilà qui est ce malcolm everett
wallace qui donc était à travailler pour
le dow jones au lit je connaissais déjà
dans les années 40
c'était déjà un tueur à gages et été un
très bon tireur d'élite et un est clair
part que l'avion engagé il avait
commencé à travailler dans les années 40
pour le lobby il était à marshall un
shérif à l'époque que carter était est
traité le prince le conseiller du prince
c'est lui qui a mis en place le réseau
politique de johnson c'est lui qui
faisait les la connexion entre johnson
et les ailes et financier texan donc ce
mal comme wallace était un tueur à gages
au service du lobby pétrolier texan on
est bien d'accord leur désaccord et il
était à côté d' harvey oswald le jour où
harvey oswald a tiré c'est ce que vous
dites c'est ce que je dis est suivi par
les par les documents alors autre
révélation de votre bouquin kennedy a
été touchée de face en fait on le voit
bien quand on voit les radios de son
crâne il a été touché de face et quand
on voit des photos de kennedy on
s'aperçoit qu'il a un visage intact ce
que vous dites dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'il a été réparée par un embaumeur de
génie du nom de john liggett qui
d'ailleurs n'a jamais dévoilé son emploi
du temps le 22 novembre 1963 donc
kennedy a subi une réparation faciale
avant le top 6 pour accréditer la thèse
du tueur unique
ouais en fait ce qu'il y avait depuis
toujours ils viennent contredire
entre les témoignages des gens qui
avaient tenté de le sauver à dallas et
les gens qui a fait l'autopsié à
washington plus tard et les témoignages
officiels certifiés ne correspondait pas
moi un jour on ne parle
billy me parle de ce john league est un
bond meurs réputé qui a travaillé sur le
corps de jane mansfield lorsqu'elle
était décapité et lorsqu'on rapport à la
première fois je me dis ça y est on est
parti dans x-files parce que là
l'intérêt c'est un petit peu fort mais
je retrouve la femme de ce ligue est
qu'ils me racontent que le 22 novembre
63 elle s'intéresse pas du tout aller
faire kennedy quelques quelques minutes
avant que la mémoire qui soient
annoncées on a appelé ligue est on là on
lui a dit on a besoin de toi pour faire
quelque chose sur le président et il
disparaît pendant 24 heures et lorsqu'il
va revenir après il dit maintenant
partout de dallas il met tous dans la
voiture de sa famille il se retrouve à
dans le sud du texas
il se met devant la télé il fume
cigarette sur cigarette et lorsqu'ils
voient lee harvey oswald se faire
assassiner
il y maintenant c'est bon on peut
rentrer cette histoire-là été
extrêmement forte et pour moi le
demander vérification parce que je
pouvais pas sortir une histoire comme ça
sinon j'avais passé encore pour en fout
et donc j'ai retrouvé la personne par
exemple qui ce jour là est partie avec
ligue est
et quand on lui demande ce qui faisait
le 22 novembre 63 il dit je ne m'en
souviens pas je ne m'en souviens pas je
ne dit pas ce que vous dites est faux
mais je ne m'en souviens pas donc vous
ce que vous dites cycliques est ce
jour-là à réparer le visage de kennedy
pour faire croire qu'il avait été tué
par un seul tir finalement ça serait
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
logique de la différence entre que
lorsqu'on voit la fumée âcre odeur le
film relatait le chris blose faut dire
le fils de 26 secondes qui est le film
unique de l'assassinât le quesnoy
réalisé par monsieur âpre odeur voilà
aidants et donc dans le pour la première
fois en france dans le dans le
documentaire lundi on va montrer une
version qui a été nettoyé de manière
digitale et on voit bien toute la partie
avant la tête de kennedy tomber et
lorsqu'on voit les photos il a plus rien
donc c'est une espèce
c'est pour moi l'explication la plus
simple même si au départ me paraissait
fruits bien c'est exactement ça c'est
une histoire toute simple les gens
essaient de la route plus compliquée
qu'elle ne l'est en fait l'histoire il
semble alors bref le
complot selon vous a été organisé par le
vice président lyndon johnson qui
trouvait les frères kennedy trop curieux
il pensait que les frères kennedy
s'intéresser trop assez assez à faire
billy à l'époque où vous étiez riche
vous avez considérablement arroser le
président lyndon johnson qui était
encore un politicien local
vous l'avez aider vous avez été en
contact avec johnson a été son
financiers à l'époque
ouais c'est vrai oui effectivement lundi
ce que vous donnez dans le bouquin
malheureusement vous le donner à la fin
et on espère lundi soir sur canal qu on
en apprendra plus dans l'ain petit
investigations vous possédez billy une
cassette ou cliff carter qui est donc un
membre de la du réseau disons du lobby
johnson vous dit textuellement lyndon en
parlant de lyndon johnson le
vice-président lyndon n'aurait pas dû
donner à mac c'est wallace l'ordre de
tuer kennedy
oui je sais c'est tout à fait exact
ce que nous avons enregistré cette
cassette
les feux avaient peur de d'avoir des
problèmes
donc on avait enregistré cette cassette
avec pelé fait moi même s'est cassé plus
est ne servent d'assurance vie
pratiquement alors si jamais j'ai un
problème
j'envoie un mois à mon avocat est là et
la bande se reproduit agritubel ce que
vous nous dites la bbc que c'est une
cassette dans laquelle cliff parker
dénonce lyndon johnson comme non pas
l'assassin enfin en tous les cas
l'organisateur de l'assassinât de john
fitzgerald kennedy
c'est exactement ça aurait vraiment
et les johnson se sont rencontrés nenê
n'a organisé doté l'assassinât alors
c'était une affaire un peu trop
compliqué pour eux ils ont délégué
allure professionnelle ne savais pas que
des tueurs ne savais pas ce qu'était les
engeances ouais c'était légal il se
disait que les kennedy c'est des gamins
de boston qui t'avait pas ce qui se
passait hélène vous avez une question à
poser
je demande à monsieur pourquoi ils en
parlent qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi vous en
parlez qu'aujourd'hui billy la seule
raison pour laquelle j'en reparle
aujourd'hui c'est que bon certainement
jamais eu d'autres occasions par le
passé mais il y avait à l'époque on va
le savoir ce qui a été créé lyndon
johnson ce qu'il avait fait l'histoire
de sa grille de la mienne et les
assassinats étaient que des accidents de
parcours mais est un nom des frères qui
il aurait dû se méfier du plan texan il
n'avait pas n'était pas de taille à
affronter la cour des grands et de le
clan texan lyndon avait besoin de se
débarrasser des canadiens parce que
justement il
s'il n'avait pas été du président
lui-même il passait la chaise électrique
le cas alors vous dites aujourd'hui bon
vous êtes vous êtes ruiner un billion je
crois qu'on peut le dire vous êtes veuf
vous êtes ces ag et et vous dites je
vais tout dire mais pourquoi ne dites
vous pas tout pourquoi dites-vous
seulement cette phrase de cliff carter
lyndon n'aurait pas dû donner l'ordre
pourquoi est-ce que vous balancez pas
tout compte tenu de votre âge de votre
situation à la jeune femme a passé les
dernières années de ma vie en taule com
est là que vous allez sur la chaise
électrique moi même et pourquoi
faites-vous ces révélations en france
plutôt qu'aux états unis c'est à dire
que je n'ai pas tellement voulu parler
aux journalistes certains certes
l'occasion a été donnée hier par le
passé mais quand vous les hommes a
commencé à travailler sur ces livres on
s'est rapprochés ça s'est passé très
simplement je faisais confiance à lui
bien alors will i am jean lesieur dans
télé 7 jours affirme que les révélations
de votre livre sont déjà dans le domaine
public est trouvable en 30 minutes sur
internet il suffit d'aller sur google de
taper billy solstice plus john kennedy
et on y retrouve tout ce que vous avez
mis à 11 années
adélie chez jean lesieur du para parle
du téléfilm du documentaire ce que c'est
quoi parle du documentaire est produit
et pas du lift il n'avait pas encore lu
jean lesieur nous fait un procès
d'intention sur ce documentaire à la
pour des raisons complètement fausses et
personnel et moi ce qui me choque le
plus dans ce temps dans cette espèce de
mini polémique lancée par télé 7 jours
qui n'est pas suivi par le reste de la
presse qui a vu le documentaire qui
l'adoré ou qu'on lui livre qu'il aime
ce qui me choque le plus c'est jean
lesieur sait que c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
eu au téléphone
bernard nicolas et moi pendant plus
d'une heure à lui expliqué que la
première personne à avoir parlé de mac
wallace c'était moi dans un précédent
livre en 97 et cfk autopsie d'un crime
d'état voilà et c'est cette
information-là qui avait été reprise sur
internet
et comme je lui avais dit mais
savez-vous monsieur ce qu'on dit sur
vous sur internet est ce que ça veut
dire ce que c'est vrai il était resté
sans voix et nous avait expliqué aussi
que il était extrêmement sensible à tout
ce qu'on disait sur les états unis et
que donc il n'avait pas aimé notre
documentaire c'est son sens droite pas
aimer mais ce qui est choquant c'est que
ces arguments sont complètement fous pas
vous savez quand même gamme que depuis
40 ans il ya eu de nombreuses théories
du complot qui s'opposaient aux
conclusions de la commission warren
il ya eu jim garrison popularisé par le
film de oliver stone lui parlait d'un
dénommé kleisch aux agents de la cia qui
auraient été en fait l'assassin et puis
a eu des centaines d'ouvragés ou les
commanditaires ont été tour à tour la
cia la mafia castro les soviétiques
l'extrême droite
johnson enfin il ya que la famille ewing
cap a été accusée quoi et encore je
pense que julien est un prochain livre
qui se prépare qui accusent la famille
bush
je vous le dis donc non c'est vrai la
littérature kennedy est immense je crois
que c'est un des sujets qu'elle plus été
traités là je pense que pour la première
fois un journalisme disait ça que
lorsqu'on finit le livre on ne ressort
pas avec plus de questions qu au départ
moi la dernière phrase du livre c'est
demain je serai ailleurs parce que pour
moi j'ai le sentiment que cette enquête
la gelée terminée
il reste il reste des il reste des
questions forcément parce que parce que
j'ai pas la prétention de répondre de
répondre à tous mais pour la première
fois le 7 un livre qui est constitué des
normes énormément de preuves il ya il ya
un cahier photos vous avez des annexes
avec des avec des documents totalement
inconnu et de témoignages de gens qui
étaient au texas qui n'avait jamais
parlé et quarante ans après il parle
pour la première fois pourquoi votre
version ska la bonne
parce que j'avance à preuve
ce que j'avance des preuves et ça c'est
une c'est une première tout le monde est
parti dans des théories là vous avez des
documents vous avez la cassette et
surtout j'ai pu prouver que billy sol
était celui utilisé et une fois que vous
prouver que billy sol est vraiment le un
conseil johnson vous pouvez le croire
et puis j'ai entendu j'ai entendu cette
cassette enregistrée en 71 ou cliff
carter explique line and johnson a donné
l'ordre d'abattre kennedy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc oui y'a vraiment et billy
solstice livre s'appelle jfk le dernier
témoin c'est publié chez flammarion
parce que vous avez des questions les
les archives les archives de la cia ne
sont pas ouvertes toutes les cinquante
ans aux états unis
vous savez les archives il faut pas trop
fantasmer dessus parce que les archives
ont signé ce qu'on a bien envie de 10
mètres sont des traces écrites ce sont
des rapports l'assassinât de kennedy
s'est pas décidée par écrit il n'y a pas
de courrier il a pas de correspondance
ils ont détruit tout ce qu'ils voulaient
détruire tout ce qui pourrait incriminer
quelqu'un il le balance bien merci
beaucoup
la suite c'est l'homme n'aurait pas un
contradicteur qui revient dans quelques
semaines vous démontrez de par a plus b
que votre livre je vous le souhaite mais
y en aura ce normal c'est normal il est
vrai contradicteur avec de vrais
arguments panne aura moins qu'ils
s'opposeraient mais on veut pas le
contrôler merci beaucoup merci à tous
les cognaçais
[Musique]
pour continuer la conversation en sambre
hainaut et moi moi moi je pense que on
va prendre plein plein de trucs plein de
gros scandale avec des mecs comme ça
qu'ils vont arriver en fin de vie avec
pas trop de responsabilités pas trop
d'enfants derrière eux et qu'ils vont
lâcher des gros morceaux 20 et les gros
morceaux via long de ce type de
personnes amendées huilé ruiné il est
veuf et il raconte que sa femme qu'il
adorait qui s'appelait patsy qui se
mêlaient jamais de ses affaires un jour
lui a dit ça je crois qu'il faut que tu
en parles et voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils
c'est pour ça qu'il en parlait ce que
c'est vrai ce que c'était voilà plus de
famille labrune et qu'il faut partir sur
un beau coup d'éclat il avait rien à
perdre non plus et maintenant
et la jolie
paris
raté
ouais si philippe geluck
[Musique]
alors philippe quel bilan faites-vous de
cette émission tous les cas de la partie
dont vous avez été témoin voir vos
impressions cherche inad dégainer
l'extérieur alors moi je suis d'accord
avec comment s'appelait-il williams
vraiment suivi solstice avec willy je
suis d'accord moi je pense qu'il ya eu
de la magouille derrière tout ça bien ça
va bien et vous très bien écouter on est
là vous connaissez judith godrèche
magnifique judith godrèche hélène ségara
les deux millièmes spécialiste en foie
gras vous connaissez nos amis alors on
m'a dit que c'était du foie gras de
votre grand mère
non mais attendez mais vous la gav et
comment vous obtenez ce parce que là
c'est vous qui comme encas et la gabelle
pas hélène ségara on en a parlé d'un
texte catherine barma confisqué le pot
de foie gras et on n'a plus le droit je
pense que vous l'avez dit à catherine
moi j'aimerais lancer un appel je vois
qu'on libère ce pot de foie gras qui n'a
rien demandé l'arrêt retient les otages
en régie j'aimerais qu'il revienne sur
le plateau tout le monde a droit à un
avocat
au moins alors vous êtes toujours avec
ruquier avec drucker vous avez déjà
vendu c'est incroyable énorme
vous êtes déjà vendu quatre millions
d'exemplaires de la bd le chat par an
tout va bien et même encore mieux depuis
que les beaux-arts mesdames messieurs
les beaux-arts de paris vous consacre
une exposition philippe geluck pour les
20 ans du chat c'est un lieu du 28
octobre 4 janvier
et si la première fois un grand ranelagh
des plaisirs on rogne sur la pierre
concassée cet honneur personnel avant
même de son vivant même deux sont morts
et 1 personne ils annulaient jamais
l'école des beaux-arts n'avait ouvert
ses portes à la bande dessinée ou au
dessin d'humour un donc
j'inaugure
non voilà on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
et pier-luc marié do
je voulais vous raconter en deux mois à
quoi va servir ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui vous allez à paraître dans
le mur vidéo de l'exposition on a filmé
les 300 façon de faire le chat celle ci
est sans doute la plus originale il
vient de rentrer du kosovo
200 d'autres qui sont à kaboul pour le
moment on fait un boulot sérieux ne
prend pas toujours
maintenant ces continents
et
voilà biden alors c'est non c'est non
est-ce que depuis cet épisode philippe
geluck vous êtes devenu militariste
non mais alors est-ce qu'on peut dire
que caen et militariste quand on aime
l'armée belge comme ça j'arrivais pas
militarisme l'armée belge en totalité
je me dis que si on attaquer l'ennemi
comme ça au moins ça les ferait rigoler
les frais les on pourra les prendre et
et j'ai envoyé une lettre au ministère
de la défense nationale j'ai reçu un
coup de fil du ministre qui m'a dit je
trouve l'idée formidable belges eux
je trouve l'idée formidable oui mais je
veux et belges se trouvent ses amis
comme je les aime samassa pourrait
arriver qu'en belgique oui ou alors
renvoyé du alors hitler aurait pu faire
diffuser des trucs comme ça bien rangée
jeu des croix gammées moins rigolo non
idiak alors la belgique quand je pensais
que c'était un pays où tout allait mal
et puis je me rends compte que c'est un
pays où on peut encore rêver et on peut
faire des choses et puis l'armée belge
n'est pas débordé non plus vrai qu'on
peut le député ils sont au kosovo ils
sont à kaboul
alors si tous les gars incroyable
pacifiste alors l'expo donc c'est aux
beaux-arts de paris
et puis aussi la parution du douzième
album de le chat un chat qui s'appelle
et vous chavaz philippe sallée que ce
soir nous avons avec nos gilles godrèche
qui était à l'affiché d'un film qui
s'appelle france boutique avec françois
cluzet karin viard nathalie baye vous
dis bien d'un coup on dit parmi nous
j'ai des terminaux
vous comprenez hollande au xixe laval
[Applaudissements]
nous avons parlé ce soir gilles daudelin
fiche d'un film s'appelle france
boutique avec karin viard et françois
cluzet nathalie baye et c'est un film
sur le télé achat à achat
c'est un risque la famille judith
godrèche souvent très très bien des
produits absolument insensé alors si
vous vous deviez nous vendre le douzième
album du chat vous feriez comment pour
vous le vendre ouais mais je voulais
offert vous allez pas me l'acheter vous
n'êtes pas idiots téléspectateurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit acheter le
douzième album alors qu'on a déjà 11 à
la maison et simplement parce que c'est
le meilleur thierry parce que nous nous
dévouons fort nous voyons là l'oeuvre
d'un artiste en progrès constant vrai
qui atteint un sommet 1 et qui est très
malade et donc c'était que son dernier
album on craint pas mal
m
c'était l'été dernier on est malade
qu'on voit un film ou un livre toujours
faire croire ces derniers c'est pas mal
tout seul homme qui va changer la face à
des caméras on va lire le chat va crever
le dernier album nicheurs
j'ai failli appeler le le livre le
dernier shah un ennemi dieter ne voulait
pas moins pour moi c'était le dernier
2-2 alors vous ressembler de plus en
plus je trouve à votre créature parce
que vous êtes déjà rendu compte de ça
est-ce que vous perdez vos poils oui
j'en fais des pinceaux est ce que vous
vous frottez comme ça contre michel
drucker
oui non qu'est-ce que vous faites bien
est ce que vous faites vos griffes sur
laurent ruquier il y là et il a la dent
dure je griffe parfois non non on se
complète bien ça ça est-ce que vous
jouez pendant des heures comme le chat
avec un bouchon et bruno masure il joue
avec bruno masure parfois pendant
désordre est ce que vous avez fait des
pieds nus quand votre femme vous prend
par la peau du cou oui est ce que vous
aimez les chattes j'en raffole bien on
va vous faire philippe geluck un anti
portrait chinois
[Musique]
il dit lui que si vous étiez une injure
vous seriez quoi une injure bas mais non
mais ne soufflait pas abordé le maire de
fait chier [ __ ] de ta mère de mes deux
matches et y ait une belle la vie la
civic hull
je savais ce que c'est ah non c'est une
maladie génétique rare ouais c'est les
gens qui au lieu d'avoir la raie des
fesses verticale ou horizontale
non mais attendez déco n'est pas parce
que c'est grave parce que si vous
glissez par exemple sur une rampe
d'escalier en qu'hilton etc c'est normal
ça fait si vous souffrez de silic hulse
a fait un accident cardio vasculaire
un vice vice président des états unis
dont le président des gens à vis en
lui-même d'ampleur un supplice
suppositoire la téléréalité attaque
supplice du pal pour un chat qui a passé
si vous étiez une cicatrice est très
bonne c'est à dire si fils du pal pour
un chef c'est l'avion cicatrice je pense
que tu peux partir merci unifier nos
rangs et voilà
si vous étiez une cicatrice là une
cicatrice au monsieur un jour ouvert le
bras comme ça et ma femme était ce
jour-là enceinte de huit mois et demi
lui on était à l'étranger en
tchécoslovaquie on est arrivé à
l'hôpital
ils ont cru que c'est elle qui venait
pour accoucher ils l'ont emmené et moi
je suis restée là le saigner dans la
salle d'attenté
c'est vrai avant qu'elle puisse leur
expliquer en tchécoslovaquie c'était
pour moi keeper des mon sens si vous
étiez un poison le hareng alors il ya
dix ans un poisson un poison mais
beaucoup de harengs ça peu intoxiquées
finalement 5ème le foie gras de mes
élèves bien j'en parle plus une
infirmité vous si vous étiez mené à ça
alors là franchement le deuxième tireur
de kenny parce qu'au moins je saurai si
vous étiez une p la télé réalité
si vous étiez une torture de la télé
réalité
si vous étiez une humiliation perdre
dans un truc de télé réalité
si vous étiez vous
luc un terroriste nikos aliagas
ça va
[Musique]
messieurs
j'accueille maintenant pierre botton
[Musique]
pierre botton bonsoir vous êtes devenu
un auteur prolixe puisque après mes
chers amis et il y a toujours des
complices vous publié chez flammarion
j'aime la vie comment remonter la pente
c'est le récit d'une résurrection la
vôtre la naissance du nouveau pierre
botton et l'art est le récit de vos
forfaits
voilà un beau message un must comment
remonter la pente
forfait à [ __ ] c'est la dette un peu
mais c'est pas un montage celle là ne
sera pas trop difficile alors monté très
monte alors alors dont celui vous parlez
du pierre botton d'avant celui d'avant
la mort et la résurrection
vous dites avancées comme un bulldozer
ne prenons garde à personne et vous
parlez de vos parents détruit par la
saisie de leurs meubles à cause de
l'ancien pierre botton de vos enfants en
larmes quand les huissiers saisissent
les peluches des enfants avec qui
l'ancien pierre botton n'avait jamais
pris 1 avait jamais pris un bain donc
cet ancien pierre breton vous le vous
détestez aujourd'hui vous l'aurez voulu
renier pour le lissier aussi un parlant
il faut bien ils ont des enfants les
huissiers aussi les suisses ils
choisissent les peluches les huissiers
sont des pervers armand quand ils ont
des gosses chez pas enfin ils en font
des cadeaux ils ont offert des cadeaux
c'est lorsque ça s'est passé j'ai
effectivement téléphoner en disant vous
êtes sûr vous avez le droit de prendre
les joies des enfants et on m'a répondu
mais
moi quand et c'est une phrase qui est
pas complètement idiote d'ailleurs quand
on vivait dans les cités les enfants
jouent avec des cartons donc vos enfants
seront réglés carte
voilà vous savez à propos de huissiers
et de saisie vous savez ce que le
professeur choron hara kiri avait fait
parce qu'il était régulièrement saisi
par les huissiers qui prenait les
meubles raid 1 et donc il y avait fait
construire des meubles plus grand que
les portes et les fenêtres
ils ont jamais pu les sortir en tout cas
en tout cas ce que j'écris dans le livre
c'est qu'il faut accepter tout cela et
essayer de se dire qu et c'est vraiment
l'analyse qu'il faut faire à la base sur
le seuil est de se relever c'est de
toujours considérer qu'on est à
l'origine de cela
dire que très honnêtement si j'avais pas
fait les excès étaler ma fortune et
ainsi de suite
j'aurais pas eu ce retour là la
meilleure preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
crois que j'étale ce que je suis et j'ai
un retour tout à fait différent voilà
est-ce que vous allez être aussi bon que
vous avez été mauvais j'en serais rien
cherche pas être bon sur surtout avec
moi même voilà vous êtes dans la
rédemption
il est dans la rédemption exactement le
rôle anciens pierre botton n'existe plus
aujourd'hui vous avez en face de vous le
nouveau pierre botton qui est reparti de
zéro après la taule c'est ça moi non
lors de -0 passé quand on sur la
première fois le parti de zéro la sépare
de -22 millions de moins 22 millions
voilà alors d'abord effectivement il
faut admettre alors d'abord ce que je
suis on me dit dans votre bouquin pierre
botton c'est qu'il faut arriver en album
est la réalité de la faute vous dites
oui la justice a eu raison de me
condamner dont seulement 6 à jeudi que
la justice a sauvé ma vie c'est quelque
chose qui choque beaucoup à la fois mes
co-détenues les avocats tous là hein
mais la justice a sauvé ma vie de
responsable
même dans un pot de mauvaises rillettes
logement défectueuses pour les rillettes
dit le maire non mes chéris battant leur
pavillon battait comme un pot de
rillettes qui était du foie gras les non
musulmans étaient fermés tic pas le
grand responsable et de faire de ton
c'est l'argent et ils vous dites mais
c'est de ses membres c'est un peu naïf
parce que moi c'est des trucs qu'on m'a
dit quand j' avais je pas dix ans mais
vous dites c'est pas l'argent qu'il faut
mettre sommet de son échelle de valeur
c'est la famille super 15 h vous avez
mais c'est quand même fou que vous ayez
attendu cet âge là pour le pour le
comprendre on vous l'avait dit quand
vous croyez pas dit quand vous étiez
petit ça non mais non seulement ça vous
croyez pas qu'on est élevé dans une
société où les tous les codes de la
réussite sont des codes de décote par
rapport aux réseaux société les gamins
dans les banlieues ils veulent des
chaussures de marque qui valent à fric
fou on est pris dans une dans une
enveloppe dans des pressions qui amène à
plutôt avoir une réussite sociale
moi c'est pas tellement l'argent durant
lequel découvrait là c'est la réussite
sociale parce que je suis j'ai basculé
avec avec la politique sera très
honnêtement si la richesse en scène
toute possession est un esclave à sion
c'est jésus essayez vous êtes devenu
c'est jésus non mais c'est c'est comme
si un être excessif forcément j'ai eu si
j'ai cru que l'argent a donné beaucoup
de choses et aujourd'hui c'est faut
obligatoirement j'ai un certain dégoût
vis-à-vis de cela c'est non seulement un
dégoût mais une peur j'ai c'est une bd
peur que je suis obligé de travailler
pour rembourser tout ce que je dois tout
ce que je dois rembourser on va t'aider
mais hier mais je ne suis on va pas te
laisser dans la merde on va lancer un
bouton taux n'ont pas facile à lire
votre en revanche mais sérieusement si
vous êtes imaginez qu'on vous ait pas
choper à l'époque vous seriez peut être
plus heureux non non non certainement
pas mais son nom ce qu'est ce qui me
permet qu est ce qui permet d'imaginer
imaginé voilà vous aider michel noir
vous apprendrez tout pour lui devient
président de la république aujourd'hui
vous seriez sont conseillés tout ça vous
seriez au sommet du pays et alors
aujourd'hui moi je suis très heureux de
de l'avis que j'ai des rapports humains
en plus pendant dix ans est très jeune
j'ai eu la chance de voir énormément de
choses de comprendre une amende chose de
lire à travers les lignes normandes
chose très honnêtement j'en ai fait le
tour et se et de la personnalité humaine
et de la richesse humaine
j'en ai fait le tour des risques a pas
chez vous aujourd'hui carbo temps une
grosse part d'auto persuasion tire une
méthode coué se dire vu que je suis
ruiné autant dire que c'est ça le
bonheur puisque je peux comparer les
deux situations
aujourd'hui c'est les vacances scolaires
je suis avec mes mais mes trois filles
je suis très heureux et je compare par
rapport à ceux lorsque j'en avais que
deux que j'avais un appartement un hôtel
particulier de 1250 mètres carrés je ne
voyais pas j'avais pas et j'avais pas la
relation que j'ai avec mes filles
aujourd'hui voilà donc c'est quelque
chose de très fort de très intenses je
peux comparer entre l'argent et ce que
je vis aujourd'hui je suis passé du tout
matériel au tout humain je dirais et et
surtout et surtout à la une recherche
sur sur moi même que je ne faisais pas
et je dis j'ai des choses à renvoyer
j'ai des choses à renvoyer aux gens qui
sont à sainte-anne chez les psys quand
on dit ben il faut une fille suit une
thérapie mois avant ça me faisait rire
non je voudrais là aussi dire bah il
faut le faire je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui doivent se faire aider j'ai
pris tous les médicaments les
anxiolytiques on peut penser je les ai
pris là ce soir c'est je viens devant
vous j'ai pas un médicament et
supporters c'est ce que vous dites est
très juste je me souviens de vous venons
dans cette émission
bourré de tranquillisants tremblant
incapable de parler mais ayant appelé
quatre fois avant pour ce chantier avec
vous et ce soir vous êtes tout à fait
naturel vous aider à bien dans votre
peau
ça nous fait plaisir voilà merci
beaucoup
c'est fait
en fait en fait simplement osé y ait mis
autant d'années pour découvrir que la
famille c'est plus important que
l'argent ceci étant ces enfants si elle
est rigide au cra qui comprendrait quand
même que je suis obligé d'en venir aux
suites judiciaires de la sphère noire
botton qui est toujours en cours
le procès s'est terminé le 16 octobre
dernier et le jugement est en délibéré
il sera rendu le 14 novembre
alors évidemment bon le procès portait
sur les versements par des entreprises
de bâtiment et travaux publics dont
bouygues d'ailleurs d'argent sur des
comptes suisses
et il ya eu jusqu'à 9 millions de francs
qui ont été versés voilà alors la fille
de michel noir à mme valérie est venu
expliquer à la barre donc qu'elle avait
fait des voyages à genève pour aller
chercher de l'argent pour son père de
l'argent qu'ils avaient été émis par des
entreprises et qu'elles venaient
chercher pour son père pour aider la
carrière politique de son père alors
elle défend votre version parce que ça
c'est votre version
et quand on lui demande pourquoi elle
défend sa elle dit j'aime pierre c'est
tout est ce que c'est une raison
suffisante pour témoigner alors il ya
deux choses qui sont très importantes à
dire thierry c'est que c'est le parquet
qui l'a fait citer c'est à dire que moi
j'ai eu plus de six procès est ce qu'on
peut imaginer quelle aurait été le poids
ce témoignage est est ce que j'aurais
été condamné à cinq ans de prison si
anne était venu témoigner à ma demande
en 1996 donc moi j'ai toujours souhaité
qu anne valérie ne soit pas mise au
milieu de tout cela
elle a été interrogée par plus de quatre
ou cinq juges d'instruction aucun juge
d'instruction n'a souhaité organiser
cette confrontation dans le cabinet d'un
juge d'instruction
entre année son père ç'a eu lieu c'est
un choix qui a été fait elle a décidé de
venir ça lui appartient
je respecte énormément anne valérie on
comprendra que je la respecte
en dehors du témoignage qu'elle vient de
faire puisqu'elle a répété dix fois
alors dans les débats on a quand même
appris un truc moi je veux bien croire
vous soyez complètement maintenant
passer de l'autre côté on
on félicite on est tous très contents de
ça parce que ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir sur le plan le comprendre on n'a
pas appris un truc j'ai dit quelque
chose le premier jour parce que c'est ce
que vous avez dit qu'elle premier jour
moi qu'est-ce que je vais le président
me pose la question il me dit vous êtes
mariés vous avez deux enfants suis non
j'en ai trois et puis comme j'ai un
devoir de loyauté vis-à-vis de la
justice parce que je dis que la justice
a sauvé ma vie
la troisième fille est également une
fille dans la mer est une des filles de
michel noir sert que donc après avoir eu
deux enfants avec anne valérie vous avez
séduit la benjamine qui s'appelle julia
et vous lui avez fait est avocate un
ouais c'est dallas la danse et pas de là
c'était au rêve ne pas oublier c'est ma
vie j'assume cet enfant qui est à
l'origine de ma résurrection en grande
partie j'assume bien entendu la relation
avec julia qui est une femme
exceptionnelle parce qu'elle m'a
accompagné dans tout mon parcours
il ya des circonstances dans la vie que
son histoire conscience tout à fait
particulière il y a beaucoup de choses
dans beaucoup de familles dans la nôtre
ces publics
j'ai choisi de le révéler à la justice
j'ai choisi de ne révéler parce que j'ai
je ne veux plus rien avoir à cacher et
surtout surtout par rapport à la
troisième fille est aujourd'hui je viens
de vous dire quelque chose c'est les
vacances
les trois soeurs sont ensemble
donc je vois pas je n'ai pas à me cacher
de l'amour même si l'amour est est à
nouveau à être se trouvait à nouveau
dans la famille de michel
nous on est tous aujourd'hui je suis
séparé du lien séparer de julia elle
devait pas écrire le livre avec vous
julia un moment oui tout aux femmes et
pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait parce que
les tensions sont très vives
la séparation était très vive savez je
le dis d'ailleurs dans le livre il ya
une chose qui est très difficile quand
quelqu'un vous accompagne dans une
période très très dur à un moment
lorsque vous sortez de prison les gens
ils voudraient vous voir robocop
il voudrait vous retrouver et
instantanément fort mais la première
chose et il voudrait que vous leur
envier tout de suite tout ce qu'ils vous
ont donnés et elle m'a donné énormément
cette femme énormément et je me suis
trouvé dans l'incapacité de donner quoi
que ce soit la première chose qu'il
fallait que je fasse et me reconstruire
moi même et là dedans sans doute que je
suis apparu ce que je suis en douce sans
doute encore un peu très faible c'est
très difficile de sortir et de de ne pas
pouvoir rendre tout ce qu'on vous a
donné j'en étais incapable même 1,1 d'un
donateur à la barre du tribunal a dit
mais qu'est ce que tu es devenu ils ont
dû te massacrer
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dû te faire subir
pour être ce que tu es et je lui répondu
devant le président et rem du tribunal
mais je suis fier de ce que je suis
devenu
c'est sûr j'ai tenu merci d'avoir été
monter la pente c'est éviter ce scénario
et maintenant les messieurs voici
l'idole d'hélène ségara
mais
radi
edf gan depeche mode
[Musique]
voilà je te l'avais promis et l'aisne
il est là dave gahan de depeche mode et
pour ceux qui ont oublié qu'ils aient
depeche mode depeche mode c'est ça
[Musique]
à
1 2
[Musique]
quel
soro
[Musique]
là
ah oui
ce soit
[Musique]
tu as
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien le bonsoir des fidèles veut
beaucoup de gens en france et surtout
d'hélène ségara ici voilà il est la
touche et le henan touché le voilà elle
a deux idoles dans sa vie c'est orlando
et voudront voilà alors c'est que
j'avais eue c'est vous qui avez eu
l'idée du nom depeche mode à un fossé
malheureusement oui c'est moi alors
c'est le nom d'un magazine de mode
français pourquoi pas elle marie claire
oui effectivement on aurait pu prendre
les autres j'étais écolier à l'époque
chez vous j'ai étudié en fait la mode et
on avait fait un concert petit concert
dans un pub à londres et puis nous
n'avons pas encore de nom alors il y
avait ces magazines devant nous l'a été
et puis multiples demander quel est le
nom du groupe
c'est le premier magazine que j'ai prise
et i télé en direct c'est peut-être nul
marie claire quand même alors dbs mode
c'était des pionniers vous ont été les
premiers à rendre populaire la musique
électronique kraftwerk avant vous avait
initié la musique électronique
mais il avait fait d'une façon très
robotique et vous d'une façon beaucoup
plus acoustique beaucoup plus facile
pour le public on peut dire oui c'est
vrai que nous avons repris un peu tous
ces éléments vertes et autres ont été
composés faire du bruit à partir d'autre
chose qu'une guitare la batterie
à propos l'été sera de très bon
guitariste ses synthétiseurs et tout ça
nous on permet de manipuler le sont de
manière intéressante
voilà alors l'année de l'apogée de
depeche mode le climax du groupe comme
on dit c'est 1988 en 1987 vous aviez
sorti un album qui s'appelait music for
my 6
musique pour les masses ensuite il ya
une tournée qui s'appelait tort formelle
six tournées pour les masses vous avez
acquis à ce moment là une célébrité
mondiale île le 101e concerts de cette
tournée qui était live at the rose bowl
a été filmée par pennebaker et il sort
en dvd avec des interviews de membres du
groupe un site extraordinaire c'est
pennebaker il est célèbre pour un film
qui s'appelle monterey pop qui l'a fait
en 1967 qui était un film sur la grande
époque baba il n'avait jamais entendu
parler de depeche mode quand on lui a
proposé de faire un film sur le groupe
et puis il a commencé à s'y coller il a
été fasciné par vous et par vaux femmes
il vous a suivi dans une tournée aux
états unis et il a filmé le 101ème
concert à rose bowl donc été un peu le
climax l'apothéose du groupe on peut
dire en fait c'était surtout un
documentaire sur les femmes et sur les
gens qui lui sied plutôt que sur nous
mêmes et ce qui était intéressant c'est
de voir justement toute cette
accumulation ces gens qui venaient nous
voir comme des fidèles à l'église
pratiquement qui nous suivait à travers
le pays et c'est ça qu'il a voulu
montrer dans son rythme heurté à un
transfert que les gens bien pris la
chose au moment du documentaire des
raisons on l'a critiqué pour ça mais
c'est justement de cinq films ils
parlaient de plus de 5 e de depeche mode
c'était un truc qui s'intéressait à ses
fruits dès que le public se faisaient
qu'à partir de rien il y avait ce tte us
machina on avait créé ce truc est dans
l'eau kb9 la publicité à la radio mais
rien d'autre qu'un thé des rires
et ça c'était intéressant non on disait
qu'ils ont été gavés de la superclasse
way de look dans son phrasé non
c'est plus efficace que l'accent texan
oui ça c'est clair mais mais mais mais
il a une classe folle passée type avez
vu nous y aura j'habite à gagner pour
les jeunes qui le voient pas en vrai je
trouvais encore mais il est un peu vieux
pour l'effectif est en attente
junger mais y'a pas de problème elle est
bonne et on démarre à 10 pendant trop
longtemps et la quatrième voie alors
vous devez gamme vous étiez la voix de
depeche mode donc pendant 22 ans et vous
avez sorti en mai dernier un album solo
qui s'appelle peppers monsters il faut
que je touche qui est écrit par finale
alors que généralement les morceaux
étaient écrits par martin gore
alors j'en avais un peu marre d'ailleurs
de l'hégémonie de martin gore chaussures
le groupe depeche mode
vous avez marre d'être seulement une
voie d'être seulement la voix du groupe
et vos idées de chansons étaient
rarement prise en considération dans le
groupe un petit peu comme george
harrison dans les beatles d'une certaine
façon c'est pas si la comparaison est
juste un 9 10 ou qu'il y avait un peu de
ça comme disons que j'en ai un petit peu
assez de voir que nous avions créé pour
nous même quand on a passé suffisamment
d'années dans une étuve après les choses
et de voir que finalement les rôles sont
presque stéréotypé et que sur le plan
créatif finalement donné seuil haut rien
de nouveau parce que nous étions
cantonnés à quelque sorte à l'étiquette
que des nous étions donné effectivement
j'avais écrit des chansons et puis je me
suis dit que déjà depeche mode est
compté et elle est toujours être là et
s'il fallait faire un album il fallait
que ça soit avec d'autres personnes
d'autres musiciens fallait me jeter un
défi abomey et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
l'occasion de faire oui vous avez bien
un petit peu marre d'être utilisée comme
un instrument votre voie utilisée comme
un instrument par le groupe
alors vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui l'avenir du groupe depeche
mode dépend de l'attitude de martin gore
parce que on a compris
ils vous laissent pas place et plus de
chansons avoue on se dirige vers le
split en ces termes là mais j'ai vu
partir tout récemment à los angeles j'ai
vu un homme de mes concerts elle a
trouvé ça bien
je n'a pas parler tellement de depeche
mode mais il me semble que maintenant je
me suis ouvert une porte monnaie et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai vu tes accepte
or j'aime beaucoup beaucoup pour ce
faire nous allons bientôt jouer ensemble
et nous et je fais pas je peux plus
revenir en arrière donc aussi je
continue à aller de l'avant
faire la musique et bien sûr des pluies
je ferai la musique est prêt à se
partageront sa destinée en quelque sorte
à l'orée des années que j'ai voulu
participer au groupe et je suis fier de
sa carrière où cette dépêche mode mais
nole a aussi l'appui de mon groupe
alors l'album s'appelle peppers monsters
et monstres de papier est le premier
single s'appelle i need you
[Musique]
key orlando exige l'équipe
à
il
mua
[Musique]
clermont
la moye de depeche mode
[Musique]
voilà de gannan idiot
[Applaudissements]
desgagnés paper monsters ces monstres de
papier dont vous parlez en fait vous
dites que c'est des monstres que vous
vous étiez créer vous même c'est la
drogue c'est l'alcool et vous aussi
comme pierre botton vous êtes guéri
alors invaincu je ne sais pas si je suis
guéri je crois pas qu'on puisse vraiment
guéri il y a pas vraiment de guérison à
guérison mais disons que j'ai beaucoup
changé de choses dans ma vie qui est de
cette façon je crois qu'on peut dire que
disons que je peux m'identifier à un
petit peu un monsieur bouton disons que
moi j'ai appliqué beaucoup de sous donc
les monstres oui je parle surtout de
déclin des angoisses et le fait de
pouvoir de pouvoir faire face à ses
angoisses et de faire des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas fait parce qu'on a créé
justement des monstres pour soi même nom
se cache derrière ces bombes a tendance
à se cacher derrière ça et puis un jour
il faut quand même dépasser cela alors
votre vie est différente maintenant vous
lever tôt
vous accompagnez votre fils à l'école
vous faites de la gymnastique vous fait
du jogging
mes deux fils vous faites bien quand
vous faites des exercices vocaux enfin
tout ce à quoi est-ce que vous savez
c'est bien c'est bien parce qu'en plus
je vais vous dire vous avez quand même
je pense que vous avez pris je sais pas
quelle quantité vous avez pris de drogue
et d'alcool dans tous les cas vous êtes
vachement bien
c'est bien conservés encourage à se
droguer
c'est vrai c'est re m6 arrivé je me suis
dit voilà ça c'est le seul problème de
ces groupes dans les années 80 ainsi
qu'ils ont pas vécu comme les z deep
purple un la grosse défoncer les grosses
d'un gris et finalement je m'aperçois
qu'il a vécu la même chose mais il s'en
tire super bien et les quadragénaires
c'est un bel âge pour un homme un beau
stade chiazi nom est tu connais les
quadragénaires c'est un vieux jouent
parce que j'étais des quadragénaires ue
pour le mois 41,1 à une époque quand
même vous vous aviez un ange gardien
avec vous qui s'appelait aident et qui
était un ancien des anciens drogués qui
vous suivait partout et c est ce que
vous l'avez toujours non j'ai parlé
récemment elle habite à detroit
dans le michigan avec moi une fois mais
sa partie depuis mais c'est quelqu'un de
bien surtout quand je suis retourné
précisément c'est pas mal des trappes
d'avoir un copain avec soin hélène
ségara je connais pas
la saison
hélène ségara when she was you me at six
mois jeune femme mais orlando lui a
demandé de chanter autre chose que du
depeche mode wrong mais en plus il avait
un vrai look
tu vois c'est il s'appelle pas comme ça
par hasard ils ont envahi vol des années
80 et de tout ce qu'ils ont emporté tout
cas on va y voit la mort n'a été fait
chier qu'est ce que tu fais là tu fais
un chat mais j'ai dit c'est parce que il
ya ma fille m'a demandé de dessiner à un
chat alors j'ai décidé à chaki ceux qui
se foutent avec une seringue dans
laquelle il ya des souris un ce biais
sont un peu dures à passer
ils sont un peu dures à passer dans les
deux équipes bien en tous les cas en
parlant de sa dette gagnent quand vous
repensez maintenant à cette époque
c'est-à-dire à los angeles quand vous
étiez lacéré les poignets avec une lame
de rasoir
quand vous pensez à l'overdose que vous
avez fait au speed ball au sunset
marquis hôtels b&b redoutable mais je me
rappelle pas tout ça mais enfin quand
vous pensez à ça aujourd'hui à cette
époque de ces parties de mon parcours de
ma ville
ce que je peux dire c'étaient des choix
que j'avais fait à l'époque quand on en
fait trop
comme pour tout bon c'est vrai que vous
êtes mort pendant savez que vous êtes
noir pendant deux minutes quand vous
avez fait cette overdose
au sein de cette marque est
effectivement je crois que j'étais
on m'a emmené à l'hosto je perds le home
a dit ça après coup effectivement je ne
le savais pas sur le moment j'ai froid
c'est ce genre d'histoire un petit peu
rasoir mais à l'époque je me rendais
comme je faisais je me disais mais c'est
évident mais il a fallu que j'arrive à
ce stade là pour me rendre compte de la
bêtise ce que je faisais je me rendais
compte que c'était débile et jusque là
je crois que je m'amusais mais c'était
pas c'était pas très bon est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez dire aux
gens qui vous regardent aux gens qui
nous regardent que la drogue c'est sympa
au départ qu'on en prend pour être bien
et puis qu au bout d'un mois deux mois
trois mois on en prend juste pour pas
être mal et que ça devient un enfer bien
que l'on recompte les problèmes avec
l'alcool
y'a pas de faire la différence la drogue
qu'on dit des choses qui paraissent
acceptables au départ et puis qui
entraîne des problèmes par la suite
justement à cause des excès et si je me
suis battu publiquement contre la drogue
ce beau combat était publique et et j'ai
voulu effectivement l'aide du public de
tout ce que je peux espérer c'est que
aujourd'hui moi même je puisse faire
quelque chose de positif par rapport à
tout ça j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
au cola à faire de la musique
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis lancé là dedans au départ
j'ai la chance d'avoir eu une deuxième
chance de m'en sortir
il faut pouvoir demander des dégagements
que c'est la chose la plus difficile
parce qu'ils ont bien passé moi j'ai eu
la chance d'abord autour de moi des gens
qui travaillaient pour voir avec moi
quelques vrais amis mon manager johnson
qui là aussi qui m'a aidé
ça
non non non
j'isole
[Musique]
merci d'avoir été avec joseph saint
gobain
[Musique]
tout
12 heures
j'accueille maintenant mans gilman
[Musique]
armagh il m'a bonsoir publié chez plon
un livre qui s'appelle monsieur lévy et
ce monsieur lévis et bernard henri lévy
à qui vous avez décidé de consacrer un
livre
le pitch de votre bouquin qui s'appelle
donc monsieur lévy sait comment devenir
soi même en cherchant bhl c'est ça il ya
quelque chose sans doute de la quête
identitaire mais aujourd'hui 35 ans donc
quand j'ai mes premières passions
adolescentes qui balançait la vie pardon
j'avais 17 18 ans dont un avec tout ce
que cela peut comporter comme pathos
comme accès comme sentimentalisme et
c'est vous dire 35 ans j'ai la
prétention de penser que mes passions
sont raisonnés donc il ya la quête
d'identité mais les identités vous savez
c'est je crois que c'est quelque chose
qui est factice c'est du jeu beaucoup
mois bernard henri lévy je crois que
comme j'aime la littérature gelé d'abord
perçu comme un personnage de roman de
fiction lors certains c'est c'est solal
otc julien sorel l'élégie mudry à la
rochelle moi c'était bhl que je voyais
plus comme un personnage de roman que
comme un être de chair alors qu'au
départ vous êtes une espèce de génie de
la commune a quand vous êtes petit
faisait très très brillant on vous parle
de polytechnique alors vous vous dites
faudra être à la fois poli et technique
ce qui va pas ce qu'il va pas être ça me
ferait le pas très bien
ah et puis vous raconter votre vie comme
ça c'est très bien écrit le problème de
la télévision c'est quand on a des
livres qui sont valables par leur style
on a beaucoup de mal à en parler il ya
voilà vous parler de la mort de votre
père qui sait c'est très très touchant
c'est très bien écrit mais la voilà à
quoi je ne peux que conseiller à nos
amis dont on croit tirer quand on vous
écoute
tiens baliser la page 105 allez-y et
puis papa est mort alors j'ai pas plus
devient grand où je suis devenu grand
trop vite on n'est pas dans un roman là
on n'est pas dans l'histoire de la mort
matamore brutale héroïque belle
fantasmatique on est dans la mort
brouillonne la lente
celle qui s'annonce qui envoie ses
émissaires qui fait des signes de loin
des coucous des clins d'oeil des bras
d'honneur pour la forme c'est sa petite
fleur gueule à elle je vous aurai tous
non c'est bien c'est traîner là c'est
très très bien écrit alors vous raconter
votre vie bon malheureusement là on la
lira pas avec votre style
vous commencez vous faites le ménage
dans des appartements dans des
résidences d'été à la rochelle
l'après-midi et le matin vous vendez des
fromages de seif sur les sur les marchés
mais je commence surtout en écoutant un
musicien que que je regrette de ne pas
avoir croisé sur un plateau qui était il
ya une ghilane ya quinze jours
donc c'était pour moi c'était la période
du hard rock était une formule rebellion
assez assez intense et kidira drop ou
rock'n'roll de façon générale quand
c'est vécu un petit peu intensément
ça veut dire qu'on se marginalise un
petit peu volontairement la société
ouais donc effectivement j'ai raté les
études à 16 ans je faisais ce que je
faisais un bep de dactylographie l'invs
est un agent des services informatiques
et puis j'ai repris les études à 22 ans
parce que précisément je crois que
bernard henri lévy mais d'autres
évidemment m'ont donné un petit peu le
goût à la fois de la littérature de la
conscience de soi de devenir du monde
s'est passé par lui en fait ce n'est pas
ce qu'on peut dire excuse moi bruno mais
un jour vous voyez sur antenne 2 la
diffusion d'une émission de bernard nmx
à pelleter les aventures de la liberté
et à partir de ce moment là la parole de
berlin en libye commencent à être très
importante pour vous gss de révélation
pour vol mais la parole de bernard henri
levy me fait l'effet d'un tir de ak47
dans une loge d'opéra est ce que c'est
le mort elle avait la révélation est
quand même difficile pour moi entendre
c'est une connotation et jusqu'à pas la
mienne je suis un laïc militants willy
tard
mais c'est vrai que je découvre cette
émission au moment précisément aux
écoutes alors maiden metallica et aux
gens des fromages de chèvre et c'est bon
et je moi j'avais arrêté les études à
l'époque la plupart de mes amis avaient
continué et je me suis une soirée on
était je crois que tu es à poitiers où
une soirée d'étudiants
qui était donc au dessus de moi parce
que moi je m'étais arrêté au bepc non
pas si je les ai eus et le sujet vient
brutalement son vin à henri lévy et là
je vois une espèce de chape de plomb qui
tombe de mépris voilà ce que je constate
que j'ai constaté tout de suite
intuitivement à 17 18 ans et qu' il
était de bon ton
quand on avait bac + 1 + 2 ou plus trois
de cracher sur la subban a retrouvé la
vie et moi ça m'intriguait parce que je
n'étais pas bac +3 et des bacs -3 et je
trouvais ça trop lent et je trouvais que
cet unanimisme contre lui était louche
et moi j'aime bien ce qui est décalé je
trouve que bernard henri lévy est un
type comme d'autres d'ailleurs qui sort
de toutes les formes de normalité
ça ça m'intéresse et j'ai voulu aller
voir pourquoi alors voilà il est à la
fois un bouc émissaire
c'est facile de taper dessus parce
qu'ils passent beaucoup la télévision et
qu'en plus je pense à une époque en tout
cas il a aimé ça et il sert aussi de
faire valoir dans certains cénacles où
pour se faire reconnaître ou élire de
ses propres camarades dont il est de bon
ton de dire que c'est une merde ouais
c'est un honneur de pouvoir quand même
de pouvoir c'est un homme de pouvoir
c'est un homme qui est il aime le
pouvoir la manipulation la pensée le
pouvoir c'est toujours mal perçue mal
vécu on se sent à l'aise et sylvain dans
des gens vierge des gens compagne main
quand les mains propres évidemment et
puis on se rend compte qu'une 1 qui
assume le fait d'aimer le pouvoir d'y
être parfois et ça ça passe passe mais
pourquoi bernard henri lévy pourquoi pas
finkielkraut et peut-être que moi j'ai
35 ans donc je suis né pile en 68 on est
une génération moyenne oui c'est ça
médiocre on n'a pas vécu grand chose on
est une génération en quête de son
événement on ne trouve pas à l'heure où
l'un vante souvent ceux des conneries
c'est factice et que lui incarner sans
doute une espèce du romantisme se sait
que le mot lui plairait pas
c'est bien ça témoigne à visage
découvert ça t'a fait du bien d'en
parler tant vais t'en sortir ah là là je
je je vis cette émission comme une
séance de psy toute façon commencer
non alors ce qu'il faut dire aussi parce
que le livre est vraiment je le dis
encore une fois a super bien écrit et
c'est difficile d'en parler mais avant
de avant de décider de devenir écrivain
vous fait un petit crochet par la part
la politique vous fait une description
très drôle du milieu politique c'était
assez c'est assez savoureux et à un
moment jack lang vous dit au sujet de
bernard henri lévy j'aimerais avoir son
talent j'en ferai un meilleur usage il
était agacé de deux succès de bernard il
évite certaines voulaient terme et
levitin type quoi qu'on en pense
qui depuis trente ans et dans le paysage
ouais il ya une semaine vous receviez
béglé sur ces célébrités
c'est la célèbre j'ai vite et voilà on
n'y peut rien on peut le dégommer une
fois on essaie une deuxième fois une
troisième fois il est toujours là ça
veut quand même dire quelque chose
inquiets qui chatouille quelque part un
tout petit peu il ya un mot de cocteau
qui y la mémoire qui dit je crois les
autres on l'est on les envisage moi en
me dévisage voilà c'est je crois ce qui
avait barré la vie on la connaît son
visage sa femme pourquoi pas sa chemise
énormément mais on n'a pas envisagé
autrement dit les gens qui me taper
dessus 10 et moi je disais tu allumes a
demandé les villes après il ya un livre
qui sort ces jours-ci c'est ça le truc
avec lequel on peut pas parler c'est
qu'il faut le lire d'abord il faudrait
c est un livre qui sort ces jours-ci
d'un penseur éminent marcel gaucher je
ne serais incapable d'assumer plus de
cinq minutes de discussion sur 300 pages
il ne trouve qu'une histoire des
intellectuels endroit il ya un seul
intellectuel qui le fait pouffer de rire
en 30 ans c'est banal henri lévy qui
cale chowchilla moi si j'avais son
intelligence tous les jours je pouffe
raid rire devant les tas de gens qui se
réclament penseurs pourquoi
l'acharnement ce qui est intéressant
c'est ça c'est pourquoi à partir de thé
est ce qu'on peut discuter on peut être
mais à celle ayant tu vas chez lien
c'est pas le sujet pour presque à chaque
fois quand il nous reste plus que ça en
poche on va le sortir et là ces
pratiques alors vous décider ensuite de
devenir écrivain marc villemain d'écrire
ce livre qui vous mènera jusqu'à
qu'arielle dombasle d'abord et vous
dites c'est elle qui m'a plus appris sur
bernard henri lévy finalement mais c'est
grave parce qu'elle voit ans bernard
henri lévy une figure christique
je ne dis pas que c'est elle qui m'a le
plus appris ce qui m'a le plus appris de
belles robes et les vices et mes
lectures de malheur je dis que c'est
elle qui m'a fourni à la fin de cette
enquête c'est d'une prétention de dire
enquête qui m'a fourni quelques mots
pleins de poésie plein de justesse à la
fois plein de distance et de retraits
que moi en tant que petit écrivaillons
je n'avais pas je ne trouvais pas voilà
la fin du bouquin donc vous allez à
sarajevo parce que c'est quand même
incroyable que bernard lévy et dépenser
autant d'énergie autant de temps pour
s'occuper de la bosnie et vous retrouver
quelqu'un qui s'appelle samir qui là
qu'il a croisés en bosnie et vous dites
mais enfin pourquoi bernard henri lévy
est venu là pour quoi il a passé autant
de temps à faire tout ça est le type
vous dit bernard henri lévy mme haji
samir
j'aime la bosnie j'ai compris en y étant
comment on pouvait tomber amoureux de ce
pays
voilà je sais pas seulement un paysage
s'est pas seulement des gueules dans la
rue c'est aussi il ya cette idée du
mélange qui est exceptionnel
exceptionnel on arrive au sol et les
petits quartiers en autant de sarajevo
il ya une mosquée il ya un temple il ya
une église
ils sont ensemble les gamins jouent
devant dans la rue sous le souffle
s'atténue en buvant du thé elle dure
quelques équipes à le tchador etc
personne ne dit rien ça rigole et ça
smar je crois que bernard henri lévy a
fait ça et ça il le dit depuis 30 ans
une 25 ans c'est une de ces questions de
principe comme il digne de ses
obsessions on peut en avoir il à celle
ci qu'est la question du cosmopolitisme
on ne se résout pas à la à la fracture
des mondes à l'établissement les
frontières et c'est d'ailleurs
j'enchaîne vous faites à un magazine qui
s'appelle toc
la société interviewé et le dossier
premier numéro c'est marre des tribus
défendre le métissage face au
communautarisme
vous êtes bien dans ce cosmopolitisme la
saison qu'il en parlait en tout cas même
si vous ou si vous n'aimez pas le mot
révélations mais il ya une admiration
pour l'homme de télévision qui passent à
la télévision d'abord et puis pour
l'écrivain et comme le dit thierry votre
libraire je n'ai pas lu encore envie de
le lire il al'air remarquablement écrits
et puis j'ai la presse vous dites c'est
votre première télé ce soir et vous avez
l'air d'en avoir fait cinq ans dames et
la très forte et j'ai la bouche pleine
de tact
là il est un peu de ce point de vue je
vienne parce qu'il ya cette gestuelle
avec la main par exemple que vous avez
beaucoup aussi un fort un soir alors que
lui et blanc à la bourrin kopierre
disons merci
je suis
messieurs
où
j'accueille notre temps long garnier
[Musique]
le regard est en deuil c'est tout le
monde vous êtes le dj français le plus
connu dans le monde non je sais pas si
vous le dis bah oui c'est vrai je sais
pas pour vous est aussi musicien vous
avez une victoire de la musique en 98
patron de fo communication le plus
célèbre label français de musique
électronique et vous publié chez
flammarion électrochoc bien alors c'est
ni votre biographie ni l'histoire de la
musique techno mais un mix c'est normal
quand on s'est donné vous est freinée
par un journal il s'appelle david brin
lambert et c'est un petit peu un retour
sur 15 ans de techno et puis un retour
sur sur vous-même en même temps et je
dirais un petit peu comme comme on l'a
dit abu ton tout à l'heure une espèce de
thérapies non pour moi oui mais pour moi
ça a été une thérapie c'est vrai que
j'ai pu enfin me poser on m'a posé des
questions sert qu'on a on a travaillé
que david pendant un an un an et demi
sur ce livre est la première année il
m'a posé énormément de questions
forcément sur toute ma carrière et c'est
vrai qu'il ya il ya un moment où j'ai dû
j'ai dû répondre à toutes ces questions
et comprendre un peu pourquoi je me suis
battu pour cette musique là et ouais ça
a été une espèce de terrain peer alors
pourquoi ai je fait danser mes parents
dans ma chambre d'enfant voilà c'est pas
c'est la grande réponse qu'apporte ce
livre à l'avis de laurent garnier alors
votre premier contact avec la musique
c'est vous aviez des parents forains bas
et on en perd deux premiers contacts
c'est la musique des autos tamponneuses
c'est à dire le la disco la sole le fin
que brest voilà dix ans vous créer une
mini discothèque dans votre chambre ça
c'est absolument énorme
c'est à dire avec la boule à facettes
avec le stroboscope ouais les gars n'est
pas l'extase et des guitares en carton
moi j'avais j'avais tout tout tout le
toutes les boules à facettes
trois spots tout le merdier quoi à 8 ans
vous faites des cassettes pour vos amis
à l'école à 12 ans quand vos parents
dorment vous allez devant la chaîne hi
fi vous mettez un cas ce que vous
écoutez de la musique moi les gens
registre j'enregistrais les cassettes
pour savoir ce qu'étaient les imports ce
qu'à l'époque c'était la grande époque
des imports donc je découvre la musique
comme ça à 14 ans vous créer une radio
pirate qui s'appellerait de teenagers et
puis votre premier choc musical en fait
vraiment c'est à rimini
sur la côte adriatique vos parents vous
emmène en vacances ce soir ils ont
déposé tient votre frère sur le parking
d'un dancing et vous entendez sortant de
la discothèque
[Musique]
musique qui vous marquera à vie oui j'ai
touché toujours se disent dans mes
caisses de discret toujours well est
très long giorgio moroder tout à fait
ouais à vos parents veulent que vous
alliez à l'école vous fait école normale
mais c'est normal
alors c est bien mais j'insiste
normalienne 34 ans c'est autre chose
donc vos parents vous font faire l'école
hôtelière est alors très rigolo vous
vous retrouvez valet de pied intéresse
la soirée il a lancé alors maiolo mois
se retrouvent les faveurs de france en
grande bretagne
[Rires]
c'est vrai assez d'humour anglais en
même temps on va serrer grande-bretagne
valet de pied de vous piquer le manteau
de la reine d'angleterre comment
expliquer les bouteilles de dom pérignon
pour les faire la fin ça c'est des trucs
ça me plaît soirée avec le avec les
bouteilles de l'ambassadeur de france
il piquait les deux héros et alors là au
mudd club qui est un club très célèbre
de l'époque en angleterre prendre
conscience de votre vocation c'est là où
je découvre vraiment les djs et découvre
que quelqu'un raconte une histoire en
jouant de la musique c'est là où je
commence vraiment à suivre
suivre des gens couet est alors après
l'ambassadeur votre pote finalement que
s'était donné un petit peu votre pote
l'ambassade
j'étais triste mais il est remplacé
cette ambassade arrive un autre qui
vient à sa place
il avoue porter à manchester vous
découvrez l'hacienda et c'est là que
tout commence
le club de tony wilson manager de joy
division et new order en pleine vague
acid house vous dit c'est quoi ce truc
même avancé moi je suis arrivé un an
avant que cette musique explose c'est
vrai que
le seul truc qui m'excite un peu à
manchester s'était ce club scallon dont
je connaissais des dizaines de clubs
mais manchester n'y avait pas grand
chose mais versé d'énormes building qui
étaient là où tout se passait donc ouais
j'y allais souvent vous dit quelque
chose de brûlants venait d'entrer dans
ma vie la house music
est-ce que les 10 6e défense beaucoup
parce que c'est vrai que là où la techno
tout ça c'est quand même lié aux aux
amphétamines à l'extase et sera lié à ça
et non mais franchement la drogue en a
il y en a dans la nuit depuis toujours
depuis la nuit des temps mais faut
arrêter de se faire l'amalgamme que
c'est super chiant d'antan ça tout le
temps c'est un peu fatiguant quoi ouais
moi je veux juste savoir est ce que
quand au moment où tu mets un disque que
tu sais celui que tu mettras derrière
jamais jamais jamais jusqu à quel moment
tu mets un disque tu vas toujours
regarder ce qui se passe dans la salle
tu va regarder ta piste et à partir de
là tu peux choisir si tu peux aller plus
loin ou si tu as été un petit peu trop
loin et c'est vraiment de
l'improvisation à chaque 10 tu sais
jamais où tu vas et cette improvisation
tu arrives à la recréer chaque soir tous
les soirs on change d'histoire même
temps dès lors que tu dirais si les gens
viennent te voir comment il va le
spectacle donc tu leur propose une
musique on s'engage à faire aujourd'hui
on va voir un dj quand on va voir un
concert cbc les débuts qui doivent être
difficile quand tu dois convaincre les
gens qui viennent aussi si je comprends
pas
avec 7 points l'an dernier c'est l'un
des meilleurs dj du mais voilà du
monfort est le même mais les débuts
canadiens tués
lo gagne et merci mes toiles à et
j'accueille maintenant thierry gandillot
[Musique]
ah c'est bien tu dis bonjour non voilà
thierry gandillot bonsoir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef des pages culture de
l'express auteur d'un certain nombre
d'essai conomique est spécialisé depuis
quelques années dans le roman noir
chenil vous avez publié l'héritage will
smith la chambre de barbe bleue câline
chez robert laffont vous avez publié
code vaudou et aujourd'hui vous publiez
les locataires alors cet art un thriller
sacré très bien construit qui se passe
dans un milieu parisien pourri par le
blé obsédé par le sexe
et c'est une espèce de garrigue portrait
comme ça au vitriol de la société
contemporaine
le personnage central qui s'appelle
robert de niro mais 2e mirage-2000 son
ami la pente et voilà son homonymie est
un petit peu gênante quand même non mais
j'ai ouï jeu
j'en ai marre des tips est dans les
dents dans les polars s'appelait
toujours un petit peu la même façon des
noms un peu neutre cas où
bon il nous y tient à propos charger
chercher un nom comme tout le monde a au
début et puis tout d'un coup ses
soutiens mais si au fond il avait une
déjà une fêlure une vie peut-être eu 4
ou un truc un peu dur à porter c'est un
type un exécuteur des basses besognes
expulseurs air va parler et donc j'y
tiens elle sait comment on fait quand on
s'appelle robert de niro quand on se
présente pour virer les gens d'un
immeuble
voilà bonjour je m'appelle robert de
niro ce robert de niro effectivement il
travaille dans l'immobilier
son boulot c'est de vie des locataires
des immeubles achetés par sa société
et depuis que sa femme l'a quitté en
amenant leur fille
il est devenu méchant ouais il fallait
qu'il avait une petite prédispositions
quand même mais ça l'a rendu encore plus
méchant et surtout encore plus efficace
qui ne vit ne fait plus que deux choses
dans la vie virer les gens des immeubles
et écouter maurice andré à la trompette
il adore maurice andrieux le site avait
quand même du maurice andré pour écrire
le livret à descendrait s'ils voulaient
pas descendre et 600 cc le roi de la
trompette
d'ailleurs il a déjoué des auteurs
absolument inconnu est très sophistiqué
donc ce robert de niro non seulement il
est méchant parce que sa femme l'a
quitté en amenant leur fille mais en
plus il est très jaloux des privilèges
des des pontes des grands pontes de sa
société oui c'est dire qu'en fait il
vient d'un milieu très modeste il a vu
son père - dans une usine après avoir
inhalé des produits d'effets à zéro si
je vais m'en sortir
ouais donc donc il a un boulot qui a
cassé craque quand même mais hilton un
coup il s'aperçoit que les gens qui sont
au dessus au dessus de lui gagne
beaucoup plus d'argent il entend un mot
qui le fascine c'est big money à la cire
que lui la déprime mais il n'a pas dans
l'habitude mais là il est sorti son
milieu il a vraiment où ils aillent là
il a une voiture de marque je ne serais
pas ici
oui elle arriva il arrivé là des beaux
costards et tout mais il voit tout d'un
coup de ce mot de big money et ça ça le
fait absolument fantasmes et il voit
qu'en fait en gros il faut rajouter un
ou 2 0 à sedan
voilà qui s'appelle sulitzer lui il va
arriver ce qui à valmorel les autres
font des pauses et d'icônes en
saskatchewan les choses bien petit écart
possible et les cartes la société que
vous décrivez dans ce bouquin est
absolument effectivement pourri par le
blé est obsédé par le sexe est plus fait
c'est un peu une satire sociale et
j'avais envie quand même aussi de pas
mal de dénoncer tous les gens qui eux
par exemple achète une usine la ferme
pendant l'été vandal ans quand les
machines et quand les mecs arrivent les
quinze senti par exemple vous êtes pour
dire quoi
c'est un petit peu ça a montré qu il ya
eu des gens qui dont c'est le métier
alors donc ce robert de niro au début du
livre s'attaque à un immeuble bourgeois
du 15e
il doit donc virer les locataires pour
que la société puisse leur vendre de
faire une plus-value voilà alors je lui
dois beaucoup
ouais les armes habituelles ces menaces
chantages violence oui c'est ça alors il
est il et c'était il est quand même
assez sophistiqué donc il s ils essaient
d'abord de comprendre l'âme de
l'immeuble c'est les côtés dans sa place
dans un seul immeuble et et donc de ne
comprendre un petit peu quels sont les
fêlures de chacun quels sont les oui
c'est extrêmement voilà c'est le mot
c'est exactement ça il est extrêmement
pervers très malin et donc ils rentrent
petit à petit il dit pas que c'est lui
le nouveau proprio qu'elle est c'est
simplement il commence à inspecter
regarder un petit peu partout et rentrer
un petit peu dans la vie privée des gens
des méthodes qui sont limite excuses
nationales c'est intéressant parce que
c'est exactement qui sont ces gens qu'on
croise tous les jours dans l'escalier
lui il est obligé de le faire plus on
s'en fout l'huile est obligé de le faire
parce que pour les virer il faut qu'ils
trouvent leur leurs faiblesses leurs
fêlures sawi donc c'est en fait c'est un
type qui va qui capable de rentrer dans
les chambres de bonne pour aller
vérifier si le type du rez de chaussée
ne n'en profite pas pour faire des après
midi avec ça avec son assistante et
justement ya gilbert le kiné volet
heures avec malaise son assistante nadal
1 102 cm dans la chine et tout cet
attirail cournot assez sophistiqué
d'ailleurs dans la chambre de 6e alors
qu'il ya clip le designer automobile qui
est d'agde c'est très caricatural est
très très bien vu où il est devenu fou
de bouddhisme sa femme le fait plus
beaux restes un jour il a oui c'est ça
oui il ya alors un jeu un jour il a
hissé il a eu une phrase qui lui a été
dit par les designers automobiles donc
chez renault et il ya un peu un type de
la fiat qui doit d'une chose
extraordinaire l'homme de la main existe
depuis vingt mille ans et les poignées
de portes change toutes les trois
minutes à chaque modèle et sa cette
phrase c'est il a trouvé ça un peu de
lao-tseu là dedans quand il sait comment
ça fontas mais là dessus et il se lance
dans le bouddhisme et m'annonce a mal
terminé sa semaine très très mal
contrairement à ce que dit mathieu
ricard lou 10 ne mène pas toujours au
bonheur là on le sait ce qu'on doit
effectivement dans votre bouquin
effectivement alors il ya michel sa
femme qui est très adepte des plans et
c'est malheureux à dire que lui s'occupe
d'eux n'a plus d'elle du pain et donc
elle elle a envie de 2,2
d'abord de réussir dans la vie est donc
et donc elle va trouver quelqu'un veut
lui faire à la fois gagner beaucoup
d'argent et en même temps effectivement
d après-midi sophistiqués c'est lors de
temps vous voient comme ça des rita
directeur des pages culturelles express
vous avez l'air plutôt bien et tout puis
alors quand on lit quand on lit le
bouquin dix ans c'est drôlement salle
est quand même assez assez salée je veux
dire je me suis quand même beaucoup
marié à l'écrire ouais ouais c'est
vraiment épaules et j'ai fait ben bongo
lapin j'ai trouvé dans un journal will
say they did est né il ya déjà des
après-midis tupperware révélé comme les
dames ce sont les unes chez les autres
et là il y en avait avec des godemichés
figurez-vous avec voilà voilà
thierry gandillot ya germaine la vieille
communiste qui élèvent des lévriers il
ya louise alors la mère de famille qui
découvre qu'elle est lesbienne enfin
c'est un monde comme cela cet hymne en
fait en fait l'idée c'est que notre
fameux pervers robert de niro qui
pensent qu'il a son petit monde à sa
main qu'il a toutes les enquêtes qu'il
fallait il a trouvé vraiment les plans
pourraient vraiment tous les avoirs en
fait s'ils sont tous au moins aussi
tordu que lui mais eux ils n'ont pas de
plan mais ils sont vraiment très tordu
ils vont ils vont le rendre dingue quoi
et puis il ya des avis de l'écrivain
érotomane les dealers ça c'est le
personnage le souhait le plus le plus
intéressant du l'implant à moi que ce
serait vraiment génial c'est que comme
on lui demande d'écrire des livres
érotiques un petit peu un peu soft il
comme il en a marre ils crient quand
même il n'y a pas envie de passer sa vie
à ça il a une bible qui est un livre qui
existe un livre du design celle qui
s'appelle ma vie secrète parti et
anonyme
salif et 5000 pages cessé mais que du
cul du début je verrai un type 19e
siècle un anglais c'est absolument
invraisemblable alors comme pour pas
statique et va prendre des passagers
puis il les remet dans ses bouquins
alors ça se passe où d'autres à ses
souhaits à buenos aires pendant a perdu
tango ça peut se passer dans la
mitteleuropa etc et à chaque fois il
reprend et qui change des personnes
âgées aux communes aussi les premiers
avec les noms ou quand la satin
mitteleuropa il va prendre il prend les
équipes de football que la bundesliga il
volé en mêlant y mélange de france
français alors dernière question
pourquoi le livre est dédié adamo dédié
à l'amour parce que pour deux raisons la
première c'est que c'est mon ami et
coach quand j'avais 10 ans j'ai avec mon
premier argent de noël j'ai acheté le
premier descendant des 160 3 j'ai acheté
le premier vinyle d'adamo et que j'ai
eue le p2 en fait pour beaucoup le jeu
l'a rencontré il ya cinq ans et vraiment
c'est un type exceptionnel j'ai vu à
votre émission semaine d'asile a fait
regarder
bien au fait des doigts d'honneur dans
tout le monde en parle j'ai un petit
clin d'oeil dans le dans le livre
puisque le temps plein en japonais oui
le fameux dealer de coke d'ailleurs et
il adore tombe la neige et il connaître
tombe la neige ont chacun japonais se
souvient qu'ils voient foule ou anne
hathaway connaît et c'est pas lui qui
tombe pas des jeux qui est
[Musique]
mon père est maintenant le blind test
[Applaudissements]
ce soir j'accueille aux platines mange à
vue peut porter
là
alors on va vivre là ça fait du bien de
revenir à la maison
oui alors atteint j'ai une surprise pour
toi c'est quoi je peux refaire une
entrée oui j'ai deux bombes
oui alors liban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où est réalisé dans des aides à wendy
vaghjime toi rapproche toi de laurent
mais toi entre laurent et voilà entre
laurent et bruno bonsoir mes demoiselles
et bon d'accord je vois pas les oreilles
je vois que corti se promène toujours
avec deux bonds basse alors que les
corses
vous connaissez le principe du blind
test je veux l'interprète philippe sait
très bien indications
[Musique]
ça fait un point b l'équipe de hélène
ségara c'était vêtements branchés
[Applaudissements]
la bonne réponse ce soir voilà merci
philippe oui à ste marthe afar
robert baud ces longues années
[Applaudissements]
spécial garnier voix c'était bon garni
la trouverez d'ailleurs cet effet pour
lui philippe
[Musique]
sega
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc ça fait 3 points pour
l'équipe d'hélène ségara zéro point non
mais depuis que c'est plus ma femme qui
fait le blind test s'ils trouvent une
réponse
j'attends mon ami pascal sellem pour
jouer là c'est que les trucs de gouache
c'est bon vous êtes à 3 0
donc on y va philippe attention numéro 5
les délégués répondu et même si c'est
lui
cameron
[Musique]
alors de musique là d'accord lors la
musique tu veux tu penses que ta
répandue avant le regard de lula
largement mais alors maître contrefout
de savoir avant après mais je suis
content d'avoir trouvé un ge qui rêvant
de problèmes et j'étais content quand
est ce qu'on peut voir
hu
s'écrie alors serge après un point
partout mais les gallois l'a très bien
comme ça je sais pas j'ai vu la liste
même en leur temps à merde c'est facile
attention philippe patron
[Musique]
st
m
comment s'appelle ton ami juste une
question
bon bah ça bah ouais et amalia donc
suffi
[Musique]
moi
ouais
non c
attention bravo hélène non mais sérieux
parce que quand tu arrives tu veux je
m'énerve je suis restée toute l'émission
rien que pour ça tous les samedis je
regarde attention y'a du tout
[Musique]
il est plus qu'ailleurs
ces entraves explosé en train d'exploser
belle fille hélène ségara zélande encore
si elle te faire exploser par les
attentions fip annie lennox y featuring
redman
[Musique]
et maintenant d'en arriver là série des
banques qu donc il ya plus d'équipés
chacun pour sa gueule firme c'est
l'ultra libéralisme c'est la jungle
c'est alain madelin mais tirent ils ont
dit oui une règle oui j'ai dit tu peux
jouer aussi bien sûr jeudi se jouer mais
bien sûr de jouer
allons-y c'est très très dur vis à vis
du dollar par m
franchement je suis là mais attention
[Musique]
la révélation
le grand vainqueur est notre tagueurs
ramzy et l'équipe gagnante est celle
d'hélène ségara
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout le monde en parle avec le
cnt
[Musique]
au coeur de la ville
jérôme salle
quand même bien francois qc bernard
menez
une vraie hélène fillières david haye
sortie le 29 octobre une au solo et yvan
le bolloc'h la bd
gap est sorti le 3 novembre
dvd caméra café l'intégrale deuxième
année on chante innovateur motors et la
fiction courts sur france 2 le missile
adoré il indiqué
20h50 c'est sur france 2 et ça commence
lundi qui vient
ce cas là
l'homme s'appelle humaine en tournée
depuis novembre à l'olympia en attendiez
le cas michel dresse devant
william reymond bisolti le tchèque est
le dernier témoin c'est chez flammarion
philippe duluc et bouchara le thème du
chat chez casterman
le shass exposé aux regards de paris
middleton au 4 janvier 2004 cher
d'autant j'aime la vie comment remonter
la pente
c'est chez flammarion debian album
s'appelle les little monsters
le single s'appelle
idiot il est en concert le 20 novembre
au zénith et le dvd
poids normal sort le 10 novembre
non monsieur lévy chez plon rédacteur en
chef adjoint
nous voulons gagner
cochon avec david prend lambert chez
flammarion
le coffret de 3 cd laurent garnier
excess le guet
voilà thierry gandillot vélo
khater chez robert laffont philippe
corti là
un dur un vrai
un statu quo dit les reporters sans
frontières et hongrois calendrier 2004
au prix de 12 euros
emprisonné dans le monde voilà c'était
que mon enfant
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
déjà bien là
je n'ai plus rien à la musique décès le
legal beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
josé matière cachette les combats tess
mois après le thé vert est la tête du
ballet de l'opéra quand on lui qu'avec
moi pareil ça fait gagner des millions
les pelles coller au village s'achetant
une guitare d'occasions que rien
[Musique]
dans les cantons et alors
le
j'en sais
d'ailleurs
oh
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez en place de damas fait rien